possible c'est toi hier soir était le
problème
ouais y'a le prendre tous les jours mais
juste là ouais comme j'allais au club de
zac
le club de la butte à paris à faire un
petit tu coures une simultanéité c'était
le soir
bombardier pas de métro c'est pas
possible par votre taille en a plus
c'est pas possible va y a rien qui est
possible entrée de plain min les gens
sont venus comme des méga sardines
c'est horrible connaissent tout le monde
a marché du coup c'est quoi ça fait
longtemps que ça continue quoi
et ouais j'espère juste en tout cas qu
ils mettront mon train pour rentrer pour
noël non je crois je crois que c'est mal
parti
les calculs ne sont pas bons fabien ben
majid enfin j'aimerais bien qu'on me
prévienne 10 n'y a pas de contrat je me
démerde jour une voiture je je prends un
blabla car je fais un truc quand tu as
raison tu y rentres à londres je
l'entends d'angleterre quoi ben
franchement souvent en angleterre tu te
prends un petit avion entre londres et
lyon la saturday march est oui tu peux
faire tu fais tu fais paris tu fais
paris londres londres lyon voilà et tu
vas te voir un psy match de liverpool
paix poule
bon après le lyon s'intéresse à nouveau
la gamme intentions mais je sais pas
trop ici je crois qu'il ya la grève
aussi mais tout le monde fait la grève
en force
non mais aujourd'hui ce vin apparemment
c'est pire que nantes
ouais c'est bien de jouer contre un pont
entre de préférence pourquoi pas la
griffe la grève un seul endroit
c'est leur droit ce droit de ses droits
mais non chez moi je perds toute façon
moi je tout le temps à pied moi je
prends jamais le bus le train très
rarement
je n'ai rien fait une heure et demie de
marche qui a passé deux heures du mat et
autres enfants n'a ni bon
ouais euh non c'est sûr je te dis bon
petit machin je permettrai j'étais au
tennis là ce matin et les personnes ont
été et que de courts occuper les pouces
wayne on était bien on était bien non
c'était pas mal y avait un peu de vent
mais finalement ça va sur le court ça
souffle et pas trop donc on a pu on a pu
se faire plaisir mais j'aime vraiment le
tennis ça c'est vraiment vraiment
complet comme souvent retiens ça fait
travailler le haut du corps bas du corps
et tout s'est vraiment bien en fait
c'est c'est vraiment cool et les cours
je crois que le dur c'est un peu moins
dur que le que le béton je pense pour le
dos et un peu moins
le mieux c'est le tabac tue non ouais
mais ça ne m est à terre battue bien
mystérieux tueur au monde y est mais les
rebonds de ballack le placement sera pas
relevé
mais bon le tennis ou très complet on
appelle ça la natation sur terre paraît
vraiment où c'est toi qui viens de
l'inventer
la relève et je lui disais mais personne
ne dise à quoi s'est dit sur les échecs
tu me lâches des arbres par pareil c'est
beau quoi donc femme ça a commencé dans
sept minutes cette petite partie on sans
quoi une petite nul ce serait une bonne
opération pour maxime avec les noirs
ouais non mais en fait ce que ça sent le
buzz c'est quoi ces deux nuls et des
rapides que de base oui voilà bon après
en fait ni peau du cou c'est parce qu'il
va jouer parce qu'ils jouent langue
anglaise pas s'édifier sur le point dont
un peu la faille du moment toute
relative insolites ou alors ils jouent
eux quatre ils sont en âge d'or parce
qu'ils jouent ça aussi connais bien mais
bon ça sera un des gros débat mais de
jouer comme ça le problème entre
guillemets c'est que mais il va perdre
non tu peux perdre et peut-être qu'il a
pas envie de prendre le risque tout de
suite quoi et on voit des gens c'est
juste absolument rien sur sa stratégie
de match il peut siéger si un test de
mémoire et neil piscine anglais
fond de court mais bon c'est pas
forcément où ça c'est pas forcément son
style non non mais après bon du mac à ce
niveau normal peut être universal quand
même même si ni pau ne sent pas le truc
ultra technique carl c est ce qu on va
pas du tout non non pas traitées via
casque tout ça c'est parce que ce que
flat band zen et paumé jaurès dire à mon
avis est qu'il est très dur
non mais je pense que c'est ce que je
dirai c'est que mon avis ils vont il
doit y comprend quand même que le mcs a
du talent mais ça donne pas du tout lui
plaire son truc de jouer vite les femmes
a annoncé sur touax est un peu chauve
quoi je veux montrer oui je suis fort et
je joue vite et que des fois juste eu
peu réfléchir sera tout aussi fort et
même meilleur et donc ce côté là je
pense ça doit pas le longe en t non et
même le côté ouais ça on chante pas le
côté je travaille pas seul j'ai les
seconds ans qui bossent pour moi et je
regarde les fichiers mais pas trop non
plus n'est mais ils font tous un
magritte ou fait pas bah maintenant il
est carrément loup solitaire
non mais en fait en plus je pense ce
n'est mieux enfin c'est bien d'avoir une
team autour de toi mais quand même de
bosser seul parce que tu comprends
d'être vue partout quand même pour des
questions toi même tu content mais c'est
beau de faire 4e mondial en loup
solitaire fager c'est à dire que le mec
quand même sa compréhension profonde et
échec l énorme faim qui peut qui peut
aujourd'hui dans les objectifs faire ça
a failli y en a très peu je pense qu'ils
sont capables
d'après l'un des grains des lapinous
sols et à provoquer une petite meute bon
les faits le loup solitaire
non mais c'est beau mais il a refait
tout son répertoire solitairement en
thallinger bon bah oui j'ai laissé le
conte vlad le chef de traîneaux quoi son
traîneau de mer de me gêner à tirer quoi
il a lâché tous les chiens je veux vous
but tout seul où il y avait beaucoup de
chiens avec lui je suis parti kwa loup
solitaire dans la forêt ça le sait c'est
un peu comme at elle revenait à leonardo
dicaprio quoi sert il est seul dans la
forêt il est là quoi motiver tout le
monde
j'ai pas trop compris j'ai pas tellement
aimé ce film moi non plus mais j'ai mis
vlad en sueur parce que je lui ai dit
oui est ce que tu ne pense pas qu'en gt
academy maïmat contredit tout de suite
enfin je dis oui ce que tu ne penses pas
être une bonne idée pour great flu qui a
très bien réussi cette année il a mieux
joué en étant du solitaire
est ce que tu penses sera pas bénéfique
pour lui de rester loup solitaire pour
les candidats alémanique
alors il m'a dit pas du tout eu
complètement encombré ce témoin là du
coup peut-être mur tu as aurait pu dire
une telle connerie bon voilà il me dit
non trois semaines beaucoup trop long
pour être fou solitaire il est dit on a
deux semaines tu peux mais trois
semaines non alors du coup je me dis
qu'ils prendre et là en fait j'ai
compris qu'ils prendre en fait tout
autre que moi
de bonnes questions abc peut il faillit
comprend pas la question en fait c'est
fou je fais plein de mecs quoi paf
fallico réinvente sef machin n'ont rien
ça ne s'est pas partir non mais c'est
mieux que rien et qui tu t'entends bien
à mes raisins secs ne s'est pas partir
quand il faut partir à 8 soit
pratiquement pas varié partir il restait
qu enfin
mais quand je me rendrai à 109 pays ne
suis pas parti richard c'est ça un
problème le mec est chez toi et il
comprend pas quoi non mais velotte laden
juste normal comme choc oui et non c'est
sûr mais bon c'était juste fantastique
ce que j'ai joué devant des pour le
taquiner quoi la laïcité je sais pas il
a mordu à l'hameçon est complètement
passé à côté quite bon coup on va manger
l'asiatique saâd remettre d'aplomb
coffre où il n'a pas dû manger au
fast-food asiatique depuis trois jours
il divague quoi dit je vais l'amener
quoi il survit donc juste body qui le
mec reste que jusqu'à 4 heures du mat au
calme et vlad m'a dit qu il te fait des
prépas qui ont donné il reste dîner
quand même différent un fou pourquoi tu
dis demain dégage que fois personne ne
veut voir tighten up leur part ne fait
pas partie j'adore enfin d'oulad est-ce
que cerveau il très bon préparateur ming
ne s'est pas partir
pas du tout peut-être que je suis
beaucoup mieux passé il ya des
subtilités de comprendre quand partir
bref à bien très bien
il partit fait aboyer qui traite des
vaches non ça serait beau tatata
ryazantsev qui vient c'est tu prends un
club de golf qui commence à l'attaqué je
voulais dire un truc été coupée a
expliqué noah ça change c'est justement
de prôner paix mais le film va donc j'ai
pas aimé mais j'aime ça se fasse pas
grand chose et fait d'autres films de
dicaprio monde m'a pressé je crois que
c'est une histoire plus ou moins vrai
ouais mais qu'il était vraiment très
énervé quoi tu en voilà un cheval tout
va bien mais non genre tu vois le loup
de wall street
j'avais bien aimé par exemple à bastia
ce terme il est un peu solitaire
apprécié sa meute mais ce calme le chef
quoi c'est le chef de meute se servent
comme ryu pour les candidats quoi alors
après il ya un truc fans dont je voulais
parler c'est pas un qui moi m'a lucine
complètement à toi je sens avec les
réseaux sociaux les tweeters les retweet
les laïcs et tous que les gens étaient
beaucoup plus hype et par le match
carlston mvl qui ne servent à rien donc
là les gens au plus tôt car le scène
joue je viens voir bons latins match qui
est complètement décisif pour la crise
et elle tue sans les moins les gens
moins épais sur sur facebook twitter et
j'ai envie de vous dire les gars
pourquoi web alors là moi je peux pas
répondre au mont des cats pas peut-être
une graine fender ou bah oui ça va
partir pour une seule petite surprise
quand même mais bon évidemment dépôt il
connaît lui qui joue sa finale parce que
car ça les champions du oui mais imagine
tu as finale de coupe du monde
auxquelles est attirée kounta match
amical france-brésil genre mercredi dont
qui sert à rien qu'ils amical et samedi
je sais pas tu as un match hyper
important que la france aille en quarts
de finale
dans le garage comme le france l'ukraine
autrefois ouais ça s'étale barrage
france ukraine et le mercredi talent
petit match amical ok c'est france
brésil mais c'est amical et après le
samedi tata le match décisive
et puis on va images éclat la france la
france n'est jamais allé à l'euro tu
vois c'est la première fois qu'ils
peuvent y aller et là en fait tu te dis
non plus intéressant le match amical du
mercredi
toi tu peux te faire ta petite mise en
bouche avec le match amical ce pas le
problème mais oui effectivement c'est à
un truc à gagner un truc intéressant où
il ya de l'enjeu il ya du stress où il
ya un frémissement basse et ça gagne 37
tours ou pas je vais vous dire on ne l'a
pas gagné quoi c'est pas très grave
oui en plus il a plu c'était une
demi-finale sa fin et j'ai un peu du mal
parfois non mais c'est pas juste aucun
sens simplement n'est pas il n'y a
aucune bonne raison que c'est un match
dans les jambes alors que ses dents de
gestion ou gagner n'importe quoi c'est
pareil c'est juste un tournoi parmi tant
d'autres oui oui oui après après je dis
arcand toujours à tourner en attendant
le gagner enfin rennes ne sert à rien je
veux dire c'est comme contre moi j'ai
joué à l'open que je gagne ou pas
tellement envie je me suis très content
de le gagner si je peux le gagner mais
donc que les joueurs jouent le truc à
fond c'est cool en tant que spectateur
si tu vas vivre et un moment c'est plus
aujourd'hui quoi voilà j'ai faim je dire
c'est comme me semble évident c'est
évident comme si je sais pas j'ai en moi
j'adore federer là je vibre comme malade
quand il va faire sa tournée sud
américaine avec zéro donc je suis
content je les stades sont pleins juin à
plat et de la lettre les beaux points
donc si tout va qu'il y en a qui perdent
ça me fait ni chaud ni froid
quand ils ont finale de wimbledon quand
c'est un truc et je suis très chaud bon
pas grave qui ne doit sa part le foot et
l'ouverture ben écoute c'est juste une
grünfeld pour le vent les joueurs et
sites l'ouverture donc on les laisse un
petit peu réciter face et ultra théorie
cas pas pour le mans n'y a rien de nom
pour le moment c'est les gens maurice
allais voir série mondiale et orrit que
je tourne pas forcément ça mais
j'imagine qu'une petite idée date est le
dépôt mais en tout cas
mais attendez qu'est ce que c'est que ça
j'ai pas le truc sur facebook
bah écoutes je les tuerai talent partage
d'écran je n'allais jamais alors attends
ce possible que max et les blancs non
mais je pense pas quand mais je pense
encore moins qui veut jouer des quatre
matches ce serait étonnant mais sachant
que le jeu vous la grüne fed oui puis ça
j'aurais pas aussi vite si max avait
joué des quatre n'est pas toi non
monsieur ajouté mme coxon [ __ ] non
mais je pense que tu marques un petit
temps d'arrêt si max se fait des 4èmes
tailor made
oui mais vers s'annonce est bon alors
ils disent que check point com indique
aussi humble avec les blancs away alors
au moins il me l'a dit qu'avec les noirs
les fouilles elle va avoir pas voir le
direct va voir avec les cas parce que la
wii bakou ça change pas mal de choses
que là les noirs à l'image on eût dit
oui bon coeur il a les noirs sur l'ut
direccte mais vérifie quand même parce
que ça peut être d'être en vie donc les
images sur youtube
ouais chaîne aux filous vas-y on va les
voir vous voir
vérifier à tout le monde qu'il dit n'est
pas blanc mais tu as ils sont capables
de tout ce troll on va quand même faire
gaffe
oui venez beaublanc ok ok c'est un peu
c'est un peu la bonne nouvelle il ya des
gens qui s'attendent à un cavalier à 5
ha non mais du coup asie je veux aller
jeter un oeil dans la base pour vous
faire un petit topo ouverture met donc
je pense que comme j'ai pas vains
j'aurais bien voulu faire le plein fait
un petit copier coller de cette pratique
qui du coup n'est qu'ici c'est quoi les
coûts c4 g6 qui essaient trois des cinq
as dame b trois quarts est allé à trois
fous j'essaie d'un des trois bourses et
4 bouffe c4 ogre 24 carats lycées 6 x 3
oui bon je m'unis à vous et moi que
c'est assez rare ce faux 3 mais c'est
pas rien athlètes qui agissent avec les
blancs wen ak oui
en 2002 un an plus tôt il faut 3 plutôt
rhin l'énorme coup ses foudres
on a déjà vu y'a pas longtemps ça près
ouais en fait foule deux comme ça sur
fou j'ai 4 tu peux faire 500 de faire
doubler les pions en france paraît bon
bah met your mother faut 2 les noirs
peuvent avoir envie de toujours eu 5 des
5 eca id4 il te filent un pion mais
après tout c'est 6
ils activent à fond on to ruin qui a
peut-être des hoquets envoyé des trucs
ouais ok bon peu importe et du coup il
faut 3 ça évite un peu ce plan avec 5
les coutures sur des saints qui fait
boum boum bouffe bouffer turbo des cats
avec et quoique pas sûr alors dit tu te
dis que c'est pas du tout clair faut
prendre garde et peut-être c'est
possible et j'imagine s'est vidé enfin
je veux dire j'ai une idée comme ça dans
la tête toute la sueur aux 5,2 rebonds
et on verra si clair mais du coup tu
peux jouer peut-être cahier g4 côté noir
parce que tu attaques le foudroie s'il
bouge ta des quatre en mer est logique
donc les blancs juste partir sur le tour
d'honneur du grand roque n'est mieux que
la structure mais bon ils peuvent te
faire 2,5 un jour de faire mettons tous
les sept à ok bon possible et six autres
piégée
tu fous g4 par contre je pense que là
les blancs vont me balancer tête du
dessin qui accepte et les pulsions
doublé mais c'est pas si grave peut-être
faire un jouet f4 un premier 4 ok on au
seul enjeu à presque 3 mai à ses reins
j'ai que 66 parties dans la base pour
une bonne feuille d'après hui coup c est
ce qu est ce que tu as peur que l'enjeu
dépasse le jeu qua non pas non c'est une
question complètement bateau je t'ai mis
dans la merde avec cette question très
clairement non mais en fait
ok c'est quoi la dernière fois on a été
déçu c'est ça qui me gêne c'est la
défaite conjuguée de choc
la défaite à l'armée mais en fait je ne
peux pas dire qu'il est particulièrement
mal jouer cette partie des choses qui
sont déjà faits dont une partie déjà il
a le droit bordel ouais il n'y a pas de
honte à perdre est choquant fait en soi
et de deux il s'est un peu fait attraper
dans l'ouverture dans le sens où il
s'est retrouvé une semi tarage fin c'est
pas notre truc compte radjabov bon ça
c'est plus inquiétant on va dire vaste
parce que normalement petit beaucoup
plus fort radjabov après là il ya des
mots que je n'ai pas envie d'utiliser tu
vois je pense à des démos peuvent
commencer par par des lettres de
l'alphabet par une voyelle par exemple
je pourrais pas prononcé mais c'est un
peu ça non la partie mais en gros
ok juste ouverture ratée après mikko
mais c'est très bizarre ça mais là au
moins on y réfléchit après faut trois
mois c'est pas comme si je t'aime pour
un truc on sait pas trop alors que
l'autre va jouer tempo oui bon ben j'ai
postulé mais si max déjà réfléchi il est
plus dans un schéma qu'il a l'habitude
de fins
ça va mais en goujat raison quand la
nouvelle s'est pas trois très bonnes
ouvertures sait pas trop quand ils
perdent jamais en fait non les seuls
partis qui perd ses dents l'ouverture
devient même quand ma mère est gars ok
c'est l'ouverture
donc ok là je prends le coup dépôt c'est
un truc mais on soit qui g4g 80 c contre
carleton et caruana les parties qu'il a
perdu c'était l'ouverture aussi non
après ok tu peux aussi bien doubler tout
meilleurs mondiaux après un gros combat
ça peut arriver mais ouais en tout cas
combien gens un peu en dessous kouassi
août son niveau quand il perd c'est que
son curateur se passe pas bien c'est pas
une histoire vraiment niveau de jeu
niveau de jeu quoi bon je sais pas je ne
vois pas craqué sur sa après s'il
nippone une arme de voter quoi toute
façon je t'avais dit quand je suis allé
à la fédé russe bon j'ai des contacts à
la fédé russe attention à j'ai vu la
pièce avec les ordis est impressionnant
c'est des serveurs sécurité j'ai envie
de te dire ah bon tu as déjà des mecs
qui t'attendent au taser à l'entrée
c'est ce que j'ai envie de te dire c'est
que tu veux rentrer dans l'affairé et a
des mecs qui taquinent au taser
peut-être aussi aux armes à feu tu vois
ce que je veux dire non mais vraiment
faite en off avec ses amis des katanas
un peu des trucs non non non ils ont ils
ont dû petit taser du petit taser
portable et je pense que tu as des mecs
armes à feu j'ai même déjà vu dans la
fédération pour la ford gt mais des mecs
de l'armée carrément donc c'est à dire
que la bon c'est attaque à la kalach
non mais vraiment en fait c'est vraiment
comme ça bah oui mais d'agir quand à
cantat le président de la russie qui
passait au maître biais des fous quoi
qui vient la fédé tu as vraiment des
mecs avec des kalachs ans à l'entrée de
la fédé si tu as et ses décalages de
bienvenue sur c'est pour te dire bonjour
atteint 15
c'est très accueillante et donc en fait
bon déjà pour te montrer les ordis sont
dans cette pièce la pièce allait bien
sûr fermée à clé la clé c'est un bon
pote en fait qu'il l'a il n'y a pas
grand monde qui a la clé ya aussi les
mecs avec les avec les armes à feu qui
eux qui ont la clé tu vas donc c'est des
gens quand même assez sérieux et dans
cette pièce est une pièce qui doit faire
elle doit être un peu plus grande que
studio tu dois faire bien vingt mètres
carrés et là en fait t'as des ordis dans
d autres joueurs de réfrigérateur si tu
veux mais tu as pas un ordi page enfants
aujourd'hui toutefois réseau tout en
réseau neuronal c'est à dire que là en
fait c'est cck lâche calage 0 l'as tu
veux c'est encore au dessus et donc ses
ordis là ils sont vraiment dédié aux
rousses coffre et si jamais il ya des
matches importants comme celui là
il ya moyen de se connecter à gauche à
droite et de tout faire tourner donc si
tu veux c'est un peu ça la fédération
russe sur un moment donné les mecs se
donne les moyens n'ont ni polémiques
auxquelles h l'ont laissé entrer ni vous
tous et vous fait tourner le réseau
c'est ça fait tourner à fais toi plaisir
ouais mais pour le coup pas maxime il
est pas à poil non plus ni vos ordis et
puis là c'est pas des bandits un truc en
place ce sont des bons trucs ça mais là
c'est pas des loups solitaires en les
mecs là c'est une auteure une haute
deûle ou russes ouais mais bon c'est pas
un truc fédéral copro maximy là il a dû
la du matos
bien sûr bien sûr non mais en russie
c'est juste pour dire que tu as
l'organisation c'est quasi militaire
quoi ce militant ces militaires mais je
voyais dans le jazz il demandait s'il me
l'a déjà battu nepomuk d'hier meilleure
équipe sur bitstream vous invite à venir
l'écouter
chaque jour s'il ya une des infos assez
sérieuse dedans ouais il son jeu on se
fait en partie lente il ya eu cinq
victoires pour max et six parties nulles
dont la dernière le signe que phil tube
cet été voilà ta gloire qui te dis que
c'est des loups mais avec des kalachs
c'est un autre concept de loups ces
eurobunds merrit envoie une bombe
atomique à la fin dans la gueule tu vois
c'est toi c'est heureux renault 2.0
c'est à dire que l'art moment donné
c'est un croisement de louer de roscoff
ça donnait une race un peu spécial les
mecs ont des kalachs sais pas si tu
avais vu le monde dès le monde des
singes ray de plaintes de ce sondage est
un vrai voilà c'est la même chose avec
des loups ils sont très énervés vase et
vous
ils sont vraiment très énervé en fait
dont je devrais être des saints j'avais
lu le livre
quand j'étais petit je rêve il est en
fait oui c'est un concept j'aime bien
puis j'ai bien aimé aussi même la
version moderne triomphé 3 3 épisodes
fin 3 3 films et que césar le singe
jugeant le premier pas ok la fin le 3
j'ai moins aimé mais le premier était
très bientôt plein de sous on ne demande
essaiera vraiment un match entre n'est
pas l'excès yens qu en cas de
deux des bars et des pubs oui bien sûr
il y aura un match nul mais dimon dit
denis n'a jamais votre hymne de
l'entente n'ont jamais après on rapide
c'est beaucoup d'équilibré c'est quasi
50 50 mais lorsqu'en mai mais en lente
c'était karikal légende française où il
y avait une bête là la bête du jeu au
vent ou j'sais pas comment s'appelle
dacquois la bête
c'est dans une forêt il y avait soit
disant une bête une grosse bête qui tu
es les gens aient en réalité ça a été
une légende c'était juste un serial
killer qui tuaient les gens avec avec
une avec une tête de loup en fait il y
avait un film non mais déjà il ya le
village de village à le pacte des loups
à ya des loups mais sinon c'est aussi au
chien des baskerville c'est un sherlock
holmes est bon en fait c'est un truc que
j'ai d'ailleurs plein plein de films et
d'histoires autour de ça alors je viens
pas très longtemps le film c'est agatha
christie à greg crooked i il propose
gavaudan ligne ouais gévaudan c'est ça
la bête du gévaudan attraits majeurs
dont c'est ouais c'est l'équivalent de
great choquant français c'est ouais
c'est très méchant c'est un genre de
gros loup très solitaire aussi mais non
mais aussi agatha christie
orient-express d'excellents le bouquin
son l'orient-express il ya un crime et
kiki toi qui as je passais lu le bouquin
non mais j'ai pas lu diminue mais très
intéressant le crime de l'orient-express
est fantastique je te recommande
vivement
il ya le film aux jeunes mais je vais
pas spoiler je suis pas là pour dire bah
fallait le dire avant
c'est un cluedo dans un train en quelque
sorte donc force forcément femmes c'est
ça aussi qui est intéressant dans ces
partis l'ont finalement classique je
trouve s'excuse et pas d'autres choses
c'est ça c'est qu'on a vraiment le temps
de prendre le temps la caf ou trois qui
est joué il ya tout un tas de trucs
théorique on va voir comment ça évolue
on a on a dit l'essentiel avec fap un
peu comme les autres jours finalement si
tu te rappelles
dans les partis l'ont contre andré qui
nous a ému l on avait on avait cité les
partis après disque un but de jean avait
la partie en entier ouais bon là on l'a
pas non mais je comprends un peu le
temps on voit on voit ce qui se passe si
on est des bons voilà là nous on est des
loups on a on a une on a nos petits de
gamelle qui ont été données par par le
chef de meute puis on veut pas partir
solitaire quoi quand tu vois bien le
mans je savais bien même la déjà en fait
une nouvelle son choix va vraiment
définir la partie est ce que enfin c'est
très important parce qu est ce que tu
fais flou g4 et il va y avoir du foot
pro a que trois épreuves qui va arriver
ou est-ce que tu joues kg 4 l'été nos
structures et qu'il prend 2 3 f pour le
train après ça c'est son choix
voilà donc ça alors est-ce qu'on fait
grand ras qui soufflent autour d un prêt
ça c'est une autre histoire mais niveau
structure déjà le show accueillera près
après après il ya autant d'options que
deux joueurs là kg et 4 rouges et quatre
c'est vraiment il ya peut-être même du e
5 qui peut exister on l'a dit avec
cavaliers des quatre quand même
peut-être mais là c'est juste des
parties différentes
enfin franchement si tu rentres là
dedans c'est chaud non mais ce que je
veux dire par là face c'est que c'est
enfin c'est juste des parties d'échecs à
peinture pour analyser pendant des
heures mais tu peux passer 15 heures
cette position 25 heures à regarder les
lignes femme c'est jouer et jouer une
partie quoi c'est prince non mais en
fait en gros le fait un choix c'est un
choix et ils se valent tous quoi j'en ai
bien il est vrai un meilleur sur la
vidéo du direct à lui elle est très
agitée bah écoute et ce qu'il a fait une
bonne sieste est ce que il a bien mangé
mais c'est pas bon signe il peut il peut
être serré qui perd toujours à ça c'est
à ce moment de la compétition en fait
sur le moment hyper oui mais un jour il
perdra pop
oui mais tu peux y penser peut-être un
jour hyperbare bas monsieur peu tu peux
ça peut te faire comme les verts
évidemment ça de l'historique ne plaide
pas en sa faveur après l'historique
combo oui la forme sur sur la saison de
quoi aussi les devants et en fait tout
se joue là donc pas et même si on fait
des stats ou quoi en fait ça sert à rien
c'est sûr les grands nombres le stock
mais sur une partie du chemin à prévoir
domingue petites choses intéressantes
aussi fab je trouve que le classement en
2007 sanchez finalement de cette année
là aujourd'hui reflète bien les
et force sur l'année je trouve numéro 1
car la scène je trouve que ça a été un
vrai meneur mais souriant c'était le
meilleur joueur je trouve que caruana a
été numéro 2 malgré la fin de saison de
diglee rennes ça je sais quoi bon l'un
ou l'autre dingli rn3 great choc quatre
ça me choque pas gris chucky je trouve
qu'il a été plus fort que maxime dans
les moments décisifs
il a quand même gagné un grand prix ce
qui est pour le moment pas le cas de
maxime donc il a gagné un tournoi
décisif sur l'année et je trouve que ça
compte ça ben ouais non mais que toute
critique 4 sam ça me choque pas mv l5 ça
me choque pas y'a juste mamés aronian si
cette mam et 7 non mais bon il était
tellement au dessus et que mon nom ils
font des idées sans idée semble il
descend doucement fait qu'ici c'est très
rapide bref tu mets courageux mais je
vais peut-être guiry 6
quand même parce que vous saute c'est
très dur a nié en fait ils sont tous
mais saura déjà quand même - gago qui
revenue à la 12e place finalement qui
est bien remonté je trouve que ça
reflète quand même pas mal au final le
classement elo de normes a rejoint le
glaçon et l'autre c'est qu'un bel
indicateur de la forme du moment et pas
trop critiquer sa qua non mais en gros
tu as un top 5 et les autres en dessous
oui je suis d'accord avec toi mais le
peintre octroie tagi tout le maxime qui
peuvent rivaliser qui sont un peu en
dessous mais ils peuvent
et après c'est moins fort mais c'est
marrant parce que si maxime gagne ce
tournoi en gagnant une longue il
repasserait devant great choqué quelque
part il aurait fait une meilleure saison
ce qui serait il aurait une victoire en
gp chacun et maxime et maxime aurait une
meilleure saison mais là le fait que
great fouquet pour le mans gagné un tour
avec maxime on n'est pas gagné cette
année ça fait quand même l'a dit pour
moi donc je le truc c'est que tu peux
gagner des tournois très mal joué
d'autres avoir loupé style ouais mais il
va dire cette année du coup ça je trouve
que ça reflète bien les saisons en tout
cas le tomtom après y'a juste ne m'a
mais bon ma mais il est là au milieu
mais il démarrait avec 28 25 la saison
quoi il apparaît que 50 points quoi donc
et puis je peux finir je pense à mon
avis à la dégringolade a fait que
commencer
c'est intéressant n'a d'autre qu'un
joueur mettre un coup de talon je sais
c'est dur à dire est que nous vivons
s'attend toujours un truc
[Musique]
navarra qui à 27 16
il remonte un peu non voilà et remonte
il remonte yu yang est par contre il est
mal payé sur ça c'est donc 27 26 mai les
devants
du coup de mou fait crier plus autour de
27,63 chose
ouais thomas normand la zumba que il
bouge pas trop quoi puis là il a pris a
pris deux fois 06 avec une veine on
s'est tenus et tu vas mai à nantes quand
même 50 ans 27 57 c'est quand même
incroyable tapis panther 70 son intrigue
album ça incroyable quand on avait
vraiment bien conservés dans la lande ce
boulot du lion jeu bien aidé c'est quand
même un truc incroyable c'est un athlète
intérieure n'a vraiment c'est beau on
rigole souvent qu un malus c'est quand
même exceptionnel
c'est exceptionnel fil rouge à 27 23
je dis ça je dis ça je dis rien mais
exigent aussi un qui arrive
guillon guillon que déjà 27 12 il a 19
ans x-men way à l'iccn corps et tu vois
22 ans 27 04
mouais mais lui on n'y croit pas en
faute on n'y croit pas mais bon non mais
on n'y croit pas à une fin de carrière
[Musique]
un peu comme vite yougov tomaszewski
coin c'est déjà très bien votre mais j'y
crois pas pour le top 10 mondial et
artémias 27 30 il a un peu baissé mais
il peut revenir si ni votre pays
on sent qu'elle veut elle ne veut pas
jouer comme d'hab' pour mettre la
pression autant il veut jouer où il veut
juste précis là nous dit go vos pâtes et
vachon qui connaît pas surtout pas ou
qui n'a pas révisé
mais c'est bien j'aurai te dire c'est
bien de prendre autant de pages au tempo
est le poids contre à jabba fait la
justice il connaît ça il inverser les
coûts et c'est foutu andy coûte hyper
mal géré c'est vraiment dommage de
terrain c'est ça mange pas de pain de
réfléchir un peu tu as amis qui nous dit
pour rebondir sur un nombre qui est à
deux doigts de passer participer à la
finale du grand chef pour l'inde c'est
impressionnant à son âge en plus être
aussi bon encore en rapide en ville
juste pour venir un tout petit peu sur
un an
c'est incroyable mais c'est surtout que
ceux-ci vont en l'ont fait le sang va
être rapide beats je pense qu'avec l'âge
tu vas pas forcément baisser non mais en
fait c'est le prince et les parties
nantes parce que c'est plus fatigant
fotso focus pour 5 6 ans et d'ailleurs
ils commencent à baisser parce qu'il
assigne que films sont les partis qui
l'a pas signé
ouais ben oui oui je le rappelle c'est
incroyable y aurait pu gagner le tournoi
avec plus de pression on en met famille
il a défoncé en fait l'unique hillary
d'ordinateurs 5 il a fait son choix le
cinglant n'est pas qui veut mettre la
pression psychologique
je pense qu'il va falloir l'attaqué au
club de golf aussi crypto quoi voilà non
oui mais du coup en fait tu peux plus
rivaliser sur ton talent brut avec des
rapides blitz sur ton finning la
position le tas la main qui jouer
ok calcul terrain gras s'est vite mais
en lente c'est chaud et lui arrive c'est
ça qui est bon ça c'est un coût qui
n'est plus ou moins prévu que ça m'avait
dit grand roque celui de 55 ans premier
mois peut-être les plus malins de 5
avant parce que tu es vite que nous le
fassent eux-mêmes toute façon c'est une
prépa fable donc là j'ai envie de tenir
là c'est les lacets l'armée à l'armée
russe qui a analysé quoi je peux te dire
on ne va rien contredire du loup la
femme un niveau base de données c'est
pas une nuit encore 14 parties
écoute je vais faire un tour sur la base
par correspondance moi je vais faire un
truc pendant ce temps femme je vais
mettre les petits liens des réseaux
sociaux
parce que voilà pour un petit peu
partagé si vous aimez les échecs c'est
quand même l'occasion je le dis souvent
mais si on veut que les échecs soit plus
regardées bon favori demain après demain
que l'armée nous ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts à faire les lives et cetera
les résumer tout c'est sympa si vous de
votre côté vous jouez aussi un peu le
jeu en faisant les partage sur les
réseaux sociaux de façon si on veut que
les échecs soit plus regardé et que et
qu'on ait notre place il faut passer par
là il faut plus partagés sur les réseaux
tu vas tu feras un live avec autant de
gens sur fortnight tu serais à 300
retweete quoi les échecs j'ai
l'impression que jean joël séché que ce
n'est pas populaire je regarde pas et
tout mais d'un autre côté away mais
wayne on partage pas donc il faut un peu
de changer les mentalités là-dessus page
introuvable
voir mais j'ai pas prise j'ai pas
twitter j'ai peur j'arrive en fait c'est
ça l'argument qu'on entend souvent c'est
bizarre que la page charleroi songe pas
toi hein c'est juste de cliquer
j'ai vérifié les liens pourtant attend
le second ouais nan mais dont la raison
écoute pour moi il est trouvable la page
je vérifie ouais c'est bizarre la page
fan disponible sur facebook du jeu peut
être un truc non mais attends faut que
j'aie faut que j'essaye de voir ce show
tout un nom mais twitter là et j'ai
trouvé c'est sur facebook les liens de
partage des fois il de ne pas les bruits
et bizarre hein pourtant je les ai
vérifiés pourtant j'aime y partager
attends je vais refaire kg quitte effet
j'ai quitté j'ai quitté facebook je veux
pas aidé pour ça non mais t'inquiète pas
facebook c'est tellement mal foutu j'ai
envie de te dire ok boomer quoi j'aime
de moins en moins facebook non stop un
stage aime pas non plus ça manque d'eau
chaude un stage à vérifier s'ils
marchent
ouais ouais il marche du coup ce lien la
marche c'est marrant parce que j'ai fait
leur le truc en tout cas partagé gpu
afin qu'ils essaient linkedin tu va
rigoler fouesnant mais twitter c'est le
seul truc que j'utilise en ce moment une
colline et je comprends pas qu'ils
votent sur votre linker passé un truc
rouge cité propre peut-être
matin je trouve que je suis trop non
mais je pense que c'est quand c'est
premium eco linkedin je pense
ouais ça très premium non je sais pas
trop encore mais si linkedin suivant les
boulots que tu as sûrement quoi tu
bosses pour chercher un boulot quoi ça
peut être pas mal copains de fort le
veilleur réédite ses lames à doha et
meredith leur guise sur facebook je ne
me fais pas ton est reparti oui mais au
moins tu mets un tumeur like au moins un
like a parlé sur twitter tu vois c'est
sur les 1200 personnes
si vous voulez pas aidé une idée peut en
fait on peut rien y faire un saut sont
demande sur les peurs ou d'ipad filles
du fric ou quoi like un retweet partage
même un like sur même un petit même un
petit live sur sur twitter à la rigueur
je dis ça c'est dit c'est fait si vous
voulez partager vous partager si vous
voulez pas vous le faites pas comme vous
le souhaitez bon bah à 1,5 du coup ouais
c'est à des enfants nous lâcher ou pas
non oui alors vous ce que j'ai regardé
c'est que ça a été jouée par
correspondance un petit peu mais pas
tant que ce à quoi on a un parti par
correspondance que gestion 2009 tube
c'est pas un truc à la mode ni par
correspondance ni ni rien dont quelques
épreuves trois pions prend 1,3 ok vrai
échec une partie entre grands maîtres
mai date de 2001 ces pics est avec les
blancs tout vient de remettre à
l'honneur gerwen jo rennes c'est
peut-être
canebière je croirais ok mais ils
arrêtent et à fait autre chose de sa vie
quoi ouais après c'était après il s'est
fait piquer sa place et c'était une
partie ernst
ouais à cana ben rhodes un tutu coupe
complètement l'attendent internet en
train de nous lâcher
mais ouais ben on est en train de perdre
fable alléchant mais des fenêtres mais
je prends un différent chez moi affirme
chasse basse peut-être essaye peut-être
c'est ton ordi qui est en train de nous
quitter
ouais ma petite blague large succès
devant elle était bien placée
non mais l'homme d'un piqué sa place
clic est
bah oui c'est la blague et minutes quoi
tête à retardement c'est génial jeune
femme ilva il va entendre le streaming
mute après quoi il sut si non pas sur le
téléphone
c'est génial il rigole il rigole de
gouaix autochones il rigole de côté
femme fatale des pixelisé donc il ya eu
prise prisé fou g4 on a plus fait pour
nous filer des options des options à des
wheat des options de jeu risqué à
haffouz 2 est ce qu'il va y avoir grand
roque ici ou autre chose ça j'en sais
rien ou même peut-être h3 pour provoquer
prisé reprendre l'afr f4 par la suite
essayé de faire un losange
pourquoi pas après est ce que la règle
losange gagne marges dans ce tournoi je
ne sais pas mais ça peut être
intéressant gens réussissent f4 pour
pour les blancs bon là il y avait des
matches quatre échecs à vrai dire mais
faire grand roque par exemple les jouets
pour f4 pour essayer de faire un losange
ça peut ne pas être idiot parce que tu
vas avoir du mal à activer le fou de
cases noires il sera complètement
embourbé dans la structure de pions et
le fou de cases blanches chang'e-2 lui
sera actif dont cas je crois ça peut
être éventuellement une option grand
roque direct aussi fou eux deux et au
feu les blancs des idées aux fabricants
que les ressources du montant ouais
ouais je crois que ça revient à l'avant
c'est juste un petit web enfin je sais
pas j'ai mon ordi en pl à cela alors
c'est peut-être de le redire mais au cas
où je redémarre et je ferai un petit jeu
un truc comme ça des mondes où j'étais
en train tu es en train de te en train
de revivre la ok bon ça déjà c'est cool
non mais je sais pas aussi avec si vous
il faut les travaux c'est relou que je
sais pas ce qu'ils sont capables de
faire
l'armée s'il avait coupé le fil oui ce
sera vraiment coupé coupé quand même
normalement oui ne s'inquiète pas ça va
bien se passer bien se passer
s'il passe maxime je le vois mal perdre
en finale tu parles de nepomniachi os
avec ciné peu gagne il sera quand même
énorme favori
bon la suggestion des ordis et h3
imposition écoute moi je pense est fou
ou deux plus tôt mais a je crois co2
sale coup joué par correspondance il ya
une partie mais c'est pas des génies
c'est des mecs à 2100 compte revoir en
correspondance avec 3200 ouais mais tu
vois comme je dire c'est pas des génies
sipa ils ont pas la fin cela les
meilleurs joueurs parfois ce sont mes
fonctions prend avec l'idée de faire f4
le losange et mettre le fou en g2
salaires forains parce que la nation et
les centraux est aussi très bien dit
mais h4 et moi j'avais dit grand que
peut-être je pars avec ma vie ultra
grand angle mais aussi à l'époque il
vient de le jouer c'est la part nommé
icône c'est sûr sûr et certain c'est sûr
bon en fait le truc c'est quoi avec son
histoire de losange c'est que tu veux
jouer contre le choix d'heure et activer
le tiens puisque ton show case blanche
il va être impérial nocebo ce losange
meiway h4 grand qu un des deux grands
rock c'est le coût humain je pense mais
si le redis d'un âge 4 plus fort il a
fait des mauvais mais bon sur pareil un
site analysé que tu sais tu veux oui
c'est un minimum de connaître ici
jusqu'au 13e coup tout le monde s'est
jusque là jusqu'au 18e tout le monde à
analyser ce rappellera-t-il de ces
fichiers mais là tu m'étonnes riz qui
pour le coup parties dangereuses corps
parce que n'est pas dans sa prépa il
joue vite position il va pas être
mauvais ouais mais il est chaud du coup
ouais ouverture réussie pour le joueur
russe ouverture réussite pour le joueur
russe qui a fait parler qui a fait
parler les ordis mais maxime où le sait
il est impérial en défense donc on reste
quand même assez confiant enfin pour le
moment il n'y a pas péril un il n'y a
pas péril en la demeure mais vous aurez
pu avoir une ouverture beaucoup plus
insipides et une égalisation et une en
une heure il se sera pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est un combat ça peut être
simple après dépôt est capable de faire
de la merde à tout moment par 6,6 père
passe sont d'habitude de jeu tempo et
c'est un oui mais non mais capable de
faire de la merde tout en fait je pense
km laurent f2 pour soutenir les pions je
crois que c'est ça l'idée profonde c'est
possible du truc ne pas faire grand
puisque grand boxeur et paraît quand
même très logique bien vrai qu'il est au
thon qui flipper pierre il voulait voir
mvele népoui méfaits un futur vie pour
ce genre de match que tu as envie de
voir ces matches-là sûr c'est normal
enfin mvl champion du monde qui battrait
que des joueurs à 1800 ça m'intéresse
pas en fait je veux voir les combat
homérique face aux meilleurs enfin c'est
pour ça que l'on suit les principes lean
sportives ou là pour la peine pas
sportif mais c'est pour ça que tu suis
les compétitions c'est pour voir des
combats dantesques entre les meilleurs
c'est pas pour voir kasparov short qua
non mais encore je trouve qu'en plus il
est bien dit oui à l'unité you will be
short will be you will be short et un
tee shirt vendu assez t'as envie de voir
tu as envie de voir du kram me que tu as
envie de voir du duché rohff n'a envie
de voir tant envie d'envoyer du lourd
quoi et sûrement sur mon post bug
sûrement pas
bon dieu que j'utilise un peu du deal à
0 ils sont enfouis f4 sur cavaliers
absents quand même c'est une double
attaque de fils de [ __ ] aux iles féroé
f2 il s'en fout total qui prend h4
détourage trois genres kf5 jeu pas
normal ou foot est roi et en fait tu
veux te mettre le cavalier en quatre
ouais ok j'ai compris ils arrivent en
force
ah oui mais c'est au riz puisque les
pions en fait c'est s'aider vlad kwata 4
l'ado centre à c'est du solide et
soutenu par poutine en f2 tu as quand
même poutine qui chapote est allé vlad
qui sont là quoi c'est dur quoi c'est
une meute en fait nous nous devions une
meute de valve est ok j'ai pas trop
pousser un peu juste un peu ce que dit
s'était dit là tu peux donner une idée
de ce que les pauvres faire parce que le
stockfisch juillet pas trop inquiet
d'être sacrifiés en vous lui ça lui en
touche une sans faire bouger l'autre
c'est jacques chirac quoi quelque part
non mais lui se dit oui je tenais
d'ailleurs qui va se faire mater retient
pas pas de changer encore perdu c'est
dommage mais ouais mais du coup c'est
intéressant
du coup c'est une belle partie il ya une
belle idée
lille a dit que tu fais pas f4 ça va
très bien pour lui dire c'est que la vie
de l'île akin profondeur ridicule son
ordi enfin c'est pas c'est pas gage de
vérité mais ça donne une idée sur
demande comment comment traiter le truc
après là peut-être que des pauses
rappelle plus ans il n'a pas révisé ses
fichiers non mais c'est sûr qu'il a
révisé et fait que ça oui mais même en
révisant en en faisant que ça il ne se
rappelle pas tu peux ne pas avoir
regardé cette position précise parce que
c'est pas vraiment les couples en 10e et
c est par contre le jardinier tu dois
avoir anticipé bas sinon tu vas pas
faire un jeu 4 et que tu sais que tu vas
mettre l'euro f2 tue sa culture est ce
que tu peux le perdre non plus là tu te
trompes
les joueurs de ce niveau ne savent pas
bien trop fins bien trop fin pour eux
peut-être un petit peu plus fort au
dessus de 27,90 2800 quand les mecs
commence à savoir bouger les pièces ils
peuvent fermer avant de continuer
impossible ils ne sont pas assez forts
imagine qu'un mec comme mur tu as est
arrivé à 26,30 machine le niveau que
c'est visible 13 me en un mot un conseil
fabien pour l'instant lille car mois
après installation sur cette base rider
aucune analyse même si le problème le
reconnaît un truc à faire en plus merci
ce que nous
je sais pas comment ça marche sur chess
base mais aussi on m'avait fait
installer un autre truc ça marche aussi
dessus ou s'appelle soja niebler eni
deux belles heures ni pleurs ouais tu
peux le faire fonctionner dessus et
voilà donc ces noirs fois sur ton de
chasse base tu peux tenter là dessus oui
ils en pensent quoi battre quand tu le
champ comme cela ça le fait marrer en
fait ça chez comme let me marre et j'ai
dit oui et très très con comme meurtre à
ce qu il pense me chambrer en disant la
vérité pour dire à quel point glee
contraire il kiffe marafa cancer et
provoqué son décès sur la française pas
si tu as un lien je peux trouver
je cherchais un lien je vais dans le
tchat c'est après sinon il suffit de
chercher sur google tout à petit chef il
ya deux méthodes le petit chef qui
tienne isabelle ça comme ça bah pas mon
titre
voilà c'est j'ai trouvé et c'est le
premier en fait qui vient qu'on nous
fait cette recherche
hop alors après faudra bien vous mettiez
en français là on enfin vous avez fait
un vous pouvez acheter le dvd en anglais
mais vend donc à faire autant de clients
français avait vu j'ai fait les deux ça
sera plus pratique je vous l'envoie là
dans le chatt hop voilà bon assez dans
le tchat
twitch et la sélection sur twitter ou
sur youtube sinon je peux aussi aller
sur youtube le lien la partie en cours
la partie est en cours ces détails
moeurs qui sont bloqués alors comme
toujours les timer ils sont enfin les
pendules ils sont remis à jour après les
coups ne sont pas mis à jour pendant
pendant que les joueurs jouent là j'en
vois sur youtube aussi courait partout
sur les autres shot
petit poney que j'ai franchement la
coupe donné peau est dégueu mais il
s'est pris pour un ninja mais il a
refait son achat je pense à il le fait
tout le temps ne il s'est pris pour un
ninja
en tout cas il se rappelle pas c'est
déjà la bonne nouvelle
après il peut trouver par déduction
puisque f4f 2,6 à met à regarder à la
base et que c'est loin d'être évident à
faire mais si tu sais que tu peux fille
lâche 4 c'est facile si tu sais tu fais
après tu peux hésiter entre roy f2 ou
af83 leurs proches une possible dans
différentes coup on va voir alors si max
main car ayant f5 le plan c'est de
sacrifier le fou dessus avant on parle
pas vraiment de sacrifices quand on
échange un fou contre un car ali mais
plutôt des changes ce que ces pièces de
même valeur mais après oui pour échanger
le truc et avait ramené un cavalier vers
f6 ou g5 lecavalier c3 sera plus fort
que le fou j'ai set puisqu'il est
complètement emmuré dans les pions
blancs dans le losange
il a fait avec 4,9 en bus avec f4 il ya
un deuxième intérêt c'est que tu stop
assez bien les idées avec ses 5 puisque
tu veux prendre du plomb oui il ya un
troisième truc auquel je ne pense et
femmes c'est que tu gardes grand roque
du gard devant roc alors sur 15,5 se
sont tu vas devoir des oui non mais sur
45 jours tu fais tu fais grand mais je
veux je veux tu faire en f2 je veux dire
suis pas un grand rôle mais géré par là
que tu te tais quand même passé la
flexisécurité c'est du maquereau f4
c'est un accueil paris se met en danger
f4 faune du coup flexisécurité il a ce
petit n'en revint qui ne participe pas
aux jeux cou rouge quoi bon bah du coup
il est moins bien quoi fin mai pourront
sur l'armée qu'advient fin logique si
c'est ton plan de fer f4f de logique non
le géologie et j'espère que c'est pas
trop grave ou d'imposition
j'ai fait ça va mais je sais pas quel
point ces horribles agents pratique mais
fondamentalement lille à 0 vs il a les
héros ça doit se tenir à au poil de cul
mais
mais c'est vrai qu'en pratique ça me
parait hyper simple voeu pour les blancs
surtout en ayant analysé et hyper dur à
jouer pour les noirs mais ça fait quand
même combien de fois que maxime se fait
avoir dans des prépas dans les parties
les plus importantes
rajab non mais radjabov s'est quand même
fait avoir gris drame demi finale non
mais finit même nom mais je ne dis pas
qu'il va la perdre j'ai combien de fois
ils se retrouvent en difficulté dans une
partie décisive avec les noirs combien
de fois great choc demi-finale du
dernier grand prix hambourg radjabov
demi finale de coupe du monde
aujourd'hui demi finale encore décisive
car ça fait ça fait trois parties sur 6
ou 7 kw avec les noirs où il est mal ça
fait cinquante pour cent des fois où il
se retrouve maintenant l'ouverture
non mais là c'est chaud mais est ce que
est ce que fable ça vient du fait qu'il
un répertoire qui soit peut-être trop
trop trop petit en réalité c'est il est
trop facile à ils se gardent peut être
une grosse prépare pour le moment
décisif et boum quoi peut-être d'autres
font ça aussi qui garde la prépa pour le
grand moment oui mais parce que maxime
il a peut-être un répertoire qui est
trop facile mais ils n'ont pas gardé
pour maxime en particulier mais ils
l'ont gardé pour un truc qui compte oui
mais le truc c'est que maxime façon il a
que la grüne fait donc le matin tu as un
fish a révisé oui car c'est plus dur de
réaliser trois fichiers de te planter de
tous rappelés par regarde là tu
continues à parler d'un parti contre
dingli reine aux candidats pleins de
fois il m'a dit l'idiot il avait tout le
fichier y avait tout ce qui a été écrit
mais il se rappelle plus du 17e coup qui
est hyper important mais le truc c'est
qu'en fait dingli rennes tu sais pas ce
qui va jouer nos gonds le dix septième
coup que tu as vu le fichier il ya deux
mois faut s'en rappeler
mais là le truc c'est grand mais tu peux
révisa font le matin tu sais que le mec
va jouer grünfeld t'es sûr à 100% et
peut-être que du coup la grosse prépas
et les plus faciles à planter de a à z
non mais c'est une question tu vas pas
je débats j'ai pas la vérité à manger
pas mais
ok clairement le répertoire est vaste
chez maxim mais c'est aussi son bon côté
ce qui le connaît hyper bien problème
c'est quand tu te prends une autre
nouveauté
tu peux par son après prévu mais écoute
on va voir ce que ça donne je sais pas
quel point c'est grave mais ça va juste
falloir cinq minutes non mais je dis
enfin je prends une claque que les
mauvais côtés je me fais l'avocat du
doigt du diable évidemment ça fait super
côté puisque maxime koné sanaa alors sur
le bout des doigts la commune fans
machin c'est fantastique 1 mais je veux
juste dire peut-être que en fait le seul
point faible de ce répertoire c'est
justement dans ces moments là dans les
moments vraiment très demandé du coup
tout au long de la saison
c'est fantastique en fait et peut-être à
ce moment là
basse sur les trois quatre parties les
petits cons que le plus tenace et c'est
peut-être le seul point faible la seule
faille qu'en gros peut-être mais après
on n'a pas de conseil à donner à maxime
peinture moi je suis un palace j'anime
un stream donc je passais par là c'est
comme quand j'ai goûté les missions et
de winamax l'autre jour où ils te
parlais l'autre soir où il te parlais de
claude puel à saint-etienne fraîcheur en
gros ils vont pas expliquer à claude
puel comment faire une composition mais
juste les mecs il faut bien enfin sinon
tu parles de rien tu écris jamais aucun
artifice tu ne fais rien sinon pas du
maintien
donne moi ton avis à non je n'ai pas je
suis pas chercheur nucléaire bac + 9
donc forcément je ne parle pas bon
chassé de la discussion de comptoir qua
non mais tu vois cet objectif tu ne
donnes pas ton avis john darwin j'en
sais rien je pose des questions je ne
donne jamais mon avis je n'ai pas d'avis
de toute façon n'ont donc aînés pau a
pas gagné maxime est pas perdu et nanani
nanana je dis juste voilà on a quelques
parties on les a tous suivi ensemble en
direct parce que sur la chaîne chaise
comme on a fait tout le tout le parcours
et c'est vrai que dans cette situation a
dans cette compte aujourd'hui on s'est
souvent retrouvé dans le dur donc vous
d'où la question
alors on nous propose cahier des cinq
[Musique]
cavaliers prendrait 5
ça me prend des cinq dames temps des
cinq points prend des cinq on me
proposait ça et jouer cette finale
elle me parlait pions ont l'air
tellement fort montfa ben ouais mais bon
ok c'est peut-être tenable mais attends
à ce qu un objet d'entraînement wes
knight et 5 cm
non je dirai ce qu'on peut pas juste
faire des heureuses deux essais 3d c'est
royal
ouais c'est vrai que je peux prendre
part aux deux séances une option mais
hors bush voulait faire dame prend de me
prendre comprendre et c'est finalement
par êtes sûrs femmes mais ça fait déjà
tu flashes s'inquiéter blondie ou un
front à l'hélium et le truc c'est que tu
pourrais jamais faire ces cinq voitures
leaf ou g2 qui vont rodez avec toi mais
mes gars menaces avec h57 rh six mois il
est de fukui les filles manquer mais je
devrai faillite
ouais t'es change peut-être une fois non
non mais le problème c'est qu'on va
commencer à te faire [ __ ] des
trois-rois bouche doublé sur la colonne
h tour c'est bien sûr celle ci sera la
taille des minorités enfin non elle est
chiante au final est très chantant ouais
tour c'est un c6 on pourra fermer quatre
dessins on va avoir les deux faiblesses
on va attaquer à gauche à droite plus en
plus h saint caprais tf 5 qui peut
partir à tout juste explosé g6 et tu as
quand même deux tours un fou de l'attak
quoi ouais non c'est non je suis contre
sedan nantes duras bas du renom mais il
faut aller sur mon boucher h 50
il va le faire c'est ici ses cavaliers
des sacs mais ça me paraît long les mecs
h cinq cavaliers des 5 juste 3f deux
géants gros hockey est accablant des
singes et de fer cailloux 4 qui est des
six femmes non mais c'est horrible
curage des arrivants h5
enfin c'est terrifiant ça non c'est
assez dur que nous posions moi j'ai
confiance en maxime femme quand même
n'est pour il va jouer trop vite il va
craquer non mais mons possible que ça
déraille
ces cinq pour tout balancer ils s'en
foutent ouais mais bon des français 5
bon ok je comprends que tu t'en fous tu
étais dans l'esprit à fond
c'est bien mais bon tu as quand même un
pion - et à 0 compensation bon après tu
t'en fous pas à un jour tu peux te
l'autre c'est aujourd'hui quoi alors je
ne suis pas pu être là derrière pendant
le simultané de talent échange les dames
on m'a traitée de pleutres balaya
congolais plus à google peut être j'ai
assumé la poutre rien n'y a pas trop la
mab ils ont eu raison
mais ils n'ont vraiment que les pleutres
dans le club non ce n'était pas tout le
podium mais certains écoutent bravo à
eux ils ont six ont eu raison il faut
pas cesser faire le mec vous des changes
les dames pleutres enfin c'est quand
même un minimum un autre cadeau n'est
sous le donnait beaucoup sont très
sympas j'ai pas perdu mais quelques nus
des victoires voilà comment les mecs
faisait lui fera tout aussi l'autre ben
non je joue vraiment spécial c'était
cool quoi madame c'était sympa j'aime
bien aller dans un club comptera dix
nouvelles personnes c'est agréable que
c'était bien je suis content d'être
invité le voilà jeté coule donc maxime
maxi de l'engrais ce que tu penses que
maxime est il peut il peut ressasser
aussi et les parties ratés dans les
matches décisifs est ce que est ce que
c'est quelque chose que tu peux
ressasser dans ta tête pendant les
parties longues et ça peu de parasiter
ou qui pensent pas tu calcules dans du
beurre mais leur vote vous étiez plus de
l'opposition non je sais mais je l'aï ce
que ça peu de parasites et l'esprit
sincèrement que tu obligé de calculer
mais je reste que ça peu de parties de
parasites et l'esprit à te dire
ouais merde déjà contre gries tout je me
suis retrouvé toile contre un tel jeu
s'est retrouvé mal
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui te
qui peut traverser l'esprit est gêné
dans tes calculs
en fait pendant la partie je pense pas
parce qu'en fait c'est tellement en
prenant les échecs est en immersion
complète chez patil j'avoue je pense à
rien tu es le temple tape une notion du
temps d'aller au son de rien fait mais
en amont pendant la nuit la veille
machin bien possible chacun est fait
comme jamais comme on dit au foot faut
pas faire le match avant et machin fin
type ans parce que jusqu'à lui c'est
quand même un problème veulent donc il y
pense pas mais bon tu as hâte à des tas
d excellent joueur de tennis comme on
suit beaucoup le tennis si des fois
qu'ils sont complètement rattrapée par
l'enjeu pendant les matches et qu'ils se
mettent à faire mais n'importe quoi tout
d'un coup en général quand tu te fais
taper un finale de grand chelem donc
c'était pas un nul pour rire en finale
d'un grand chelem ça se passe pas très
bien pour ça que j'ai demandé ce que
maxime il peut être rattrapé par ses
idées noires en fait et je dis pas que
ça ne l'empêchent de jouer mais tu vois
ça lui fait perdre 5 10 ans il là
pendant la partie je pense pas proche ce
que je dis est en préparation en amont
tu peux y penser mais mais pendant la
partie du nom tu penses à la partie on
nous dit que maxime reste favori pour la
wild card
bon alors ça a été annoncé par la
fédération russe que ce serait donné par
un russe donc la wild card à mon avis tu
peux non mais peut l'oublier il ya pas
de faveur il faut te qualifies dans ce
match c'est tout et mails essayer des
services à la fin du monde mais est ce
que au final en plus t'as envie d'aller
aux candidats la wild card au bout d'un
moment
oui mais j'ai enfin pas comme ont vite
que fin à la terre une place de la
qualification tu ta cave envie de te
qualifier comme un grand quoi non non ça
c'est sûr juste que je veux dire c'est
que c'est que j'ai entre la donne entre
la donne enfin tant que ge a pas volé un
c'est que tu as rempli les conditions
pour la voir non mais non celui celui
qui l'aura l'aura pas volé sais pas ce
que je dis dans tous les cas loïc ce que
tu préfères une qualif directe les
rentes mais non la maxime a envie de se
qualifier comme ça et il a un match à
une victoire ça va on va juste sans rien
avoir à pourvoir s'y perdent et mal
employé
d'abord le maintien mais c'est que tout
le discours dans sûr à cause de ça que
tous les mecs et mina qui iakovenko il
ya personne à quatre sur quatre quoi
encore barriac qui sait le vainqueur de
tous qui gagnera la bonne forme et mais
je veux dire par là que c'est c'est une
grosse surprise pour tout le monde quoi
la victoire de navarra quand même
c'était un gros piège bon écoute ça joue
pas tant avec les bleus pour les deux
ouais c'est quand même étonnant ses
ouailles et qui connaît pas l'ouverture
fonds trône à farako non madame qui est
le sien qui peut être en sueur aussi ok
bon en tout cas il peut aller en finale
navarra et pourquoi pas ce serait beau
que soit navarra qui qualifie maxime en
battant nepomniachi en finale ça devient
l'idole quoi ça envoyait l'idole wind
dépôt de façon tu ne méritais pas d'y
aller alors f4 et maxime qui y fit plus
combien de temps la fab cheval un petit
moment déjà
non mais c'est compliqué comme
inscriptions et pour l'instant je veux
dire que maxime fait de notre parti il
peut pas dire qu'il déjoue enfin c'est
juste ok il se prend elle se prend la
prépa le jour j pourquoi est ce qu'on
aura soit un troll et parce qu'en fait
il a battu vlad dans une partie mais
après il ya juste un deuxième truc qui
s'est passé c'est que vlad avant le
premier tour du grand prix de riga il
dit ouais mais navarra bombao septième
coup avec les noirs c'est déjà fini quoi
sa quarantaine il la connaît pas et il
se trouve que et en prophéties quoi
enfin en amont il dit ça en amont et ils
se trouvent et la partie et au 7e kun
avoir à se planter fait n'importe quoi
et dans un fichier
voilà j'ai toujours dit ne connaît pas
lui coûte théorie machin et puis après
c'est parti on délire quand mais voilà
alors c'est sa seule ouverture une
accueille l'as cannes à prendre après
cette crise nous connaît déjà plus fort
moi donc c'est parti de là mais en fait
il se trouve qu'une explication pour
laquelle il n'est pas à préparer cette
partie là en réalité
en fait il regarde les journaux ouais
c'est toujours y avait le scandale rises
qui est chaque aussi il avait passé sa
matinée à lire les journaux ou de presse
et du coup il a permis d
il fait la came in l'ordi en vitesse sur
la partie qui était joué il est juste
regarder à ok stockfisch dit que ça va
pas ça qui arrivait dans le chic et on
va y sont stables dans les yeux donc
c'est le coût que l'ordi de jouer mais
tu qu'on savoir un truc 2,8 me faire
quoi là dessus enfin quoi il n'a pas
poussé quoi et là tu es tu as beau
savoir quel est le coût avec tes un peu
leste sur les réponses plus ou d'offre
j'ai vers autre chose qui m'a l'air
abattu rappelé shin ki moon en mieux et
voilà donc tu joue déjà en sachant que
c'est pas le meilleur coup objectivement
mais en plus tu connais rien quoi donc
ça dure mais bon du coup en fait c'est
vraiment du hasard que ce soit passé
comme ça mais comme c'est la prophétie
de vladan le délire est parti quoi voilà
où je suis juste un truc marrant sur la
chaîne c'est tout oui je vous avais dit
qu'il ne connaissait pas au delà du 8e
couvre et tient son livre basant sur
certaines variantes là dans le truc je
reviens un peu leur dif et joue le roi a
eu deux preuves de jaar sur ces 6 par
exemple qu'un ce qu'elle est ce qu'ils
disaient h5 cahier des cinq piges le
rôle 2 pour bien défendre trois plutôt
creux f2 parce que f6 tu t'en fous
nouveau ouais c'est vrai qu'il est pas
moins bien rodée en fait c'est à dire
juste avoir bloqué le fou mais en fait
il va pas les trolls sommes enfin voilà
maxime qui envoie b5
ok bah voilà donc là c'est clairement ça
va être un facv i comprend que c'est
chaud il fait de votre jeu donc décision
très intéressante en pratique
après je veux plus sait pas à quel point
c'est bon objectivement mais c'est
intéressant ce décision pour au moins
enfin faire le chien dépôts et avoir des
chances au chic et peuvent se réciter
dîner on est d'accord ça c'est vraiment
les échecs moderne genre tu feras un
coup comme des cinq à l'époque de
kasparov ce serait inimaginable non au
pourquoi pas besoin d'être dame 30
heures de huit dames ce bar tu veux c520
de jeu enfin ça c'est un truc juste des
chèques naturel ces terres que les
blancs ont par ok ils ont le droit au
centre tu vois la position ouais mais va
peut-être faire un coup de dames
par crainte et du con n'est pas aux
dames on est obligé de prendre
effectivement tu faire dame ses cinq
frères d'âme je passe d'un buzz donne
des trois dom quelque part ailleurs je
ne vous ferai pas ce qu'ils ont montré
jusque là très peu de choix d'amd 3,5
pour faire vous prend non mais c'est
très bien comme ces cinq au suspense non
mais bien joué de la part de maxime b 5
bon on verra plus tard si on dit c'est
bien joué mais là on live c'est une très
bonne note
si j'avais vu qu'on n'est pas aux dames
et là tu as les journaux le groupe
l'autre il n'a pas pris l'option quoi
mais je pense que dans les années au
xixème siècle si tu fais pas dame prend
v5 ou qu'elle prend v5 à minima plus
personne mais c'est que ça c'est
l'empreinte pataca main nous voterons
ces cinq là stratégiquement qui avec
quatre essais ça t'arrive et tour c'est
un pion arriérés dynamiquement vraiment
vraiment vraiment justifié tiens je
comprends très bien l'idée de ne pas te
faire défoncer les droits et maxime a
bien réfléchi donc c'est normal tu
prennes est sorti dans la partie mais je
peux pas te dire si c'est un bon coup
mais sur qu'objectivement s'est passé
pas la recherche de la vérité c'est pas
du great food mais je pense que dans
l'absolu c'est un excellent coup en
pratique je suis assez content de la
décision de fermeture est une certitude
mais dont quidome 6,5 d'amd trop c'est
clairement les coûts qui ont l'air et au
mkb 5 extrêmement mal joué ce n'est pas
du poker le bluff ça ne marche pas et
cheikh ba ça a marché hier contre henry
king quand même nombre économistes et
c'était c'était maxime était mal il a
gagné parce qu'il est plus fort c'est le
style de maxime var et qu'on le veuille
ou non c'est c'est patent du bluff en
fait c'est que ebay la kafala il a passé
du temps sur pression il a calculé qu'à
les f-5 machin il gagne en h4
il a jugé que la musique était très
chiante elle est il estime que ses
chances pratique dans la partie pour
gagner ou pour sauver le truc c'est de
créer un bordel sur giguère oui je vous
qu'ils jouent un jeu il joue il joue
dans son style fable il joue dans son
style c'est le style de maxime essai il
a raison de dans des parties importantes
comme ça de
d'aller dans ses convictions mais je
veux dire talent c'est un peu ça aussi
ça le talent de jeunes c'était ça la
table ça y est après là il a un autre
style tu avais été universal mais le nom
de parti qui n'a gagné que des
sacrifices spéculatifs dont tu fous
l'ordi ça marche pas d'idées - 4 - 5
mais en fait il faut il était juste
hyper fort et joe style de jeu qui est
comme ci ils vous me dites oui le
service volée c'est réfuté au tennis bon
mais au contraire a le droit non mais je
dirais tu as des joueurs qui l'ont jeu
comme ça peut-être c'est pas le meilleur
truc à faire mais c'est leur style de
jeu
moi je suis très content de cette
décision fait avant tout cas je trouve
que maxime il se laisse pas abattre il
se laisse pas mourir bêtement à savoir
attaquer dans un truc où ils seraient
pas joué ils envoient objectivement il
sait que c'est pas le meilleur coup mais
mais d'un point de vue pratique c'est ce
qu'il faut voir c'est bien joué après
comme je dis si vous aimez les gens qui
ont des styles très propre et qui
cherche la vérité absolue aux échecs
mise à part carl scène un petit peu
aigri choo qu' il est complètement dans
ce délire là bas faut être supporters de
grisou quoi ça sert lingway maxime son
jeu c'est ça il joue il joue comme ça et
ça on aime bien quoi c'est ça c'est
service volée je monte gens voient enfin
il joue dans l'esprit quoi justement
c'est bien
enfin bravo c'est l'esprit à fond
maintenant b5 b5 je pense que c'est ils
essayent de changer le cours de la
partie c'est bien joué mais c'est pas du
tout un craquage non
alors là non c'est pas du tout il faut
qu'elles sont sous la pression est
compliqué mais c'est absolument pas un
craquage du tout c'est un choix
intéressant
et voilà entre prochain appuyant après
la partie je vous dis mais je pense que
c'est intéressant parce que si nippo
prends ça va aider maxime donc ni pau ne
doit pas prendre d'après une bonne
décision est ce que tu fais mc5 dam des
trois mais avec bessengue après il est
aussi dur avec ses 5 est ok s'activer
parce que cette position compliquée à
jouer si tu vois ce passif pas très bien
résumé fab très bien résumé je ne peux
pas dire mieux que toi enfin je peux
dire mieux j'arrive viola même plus
plus mais sinon si tu as donc dans le
chat ça ça ça va ça ça s'anime dans le
chat se disputent sa sent galles c'est
bien non c'est bien c'est cool qui est d
avis que s'avivent en fait il ya pas une
vérité absolue mais là le problème c'est
pas b50 rica non mais c'est bien c'est
de la discussion de comptoir oui tu es
un con tu ne comprends rien huit fosses
situe encore plus con que muller tu as
ça veut partir à fond quoi même navarra
le comprends c'est freine pas les
discussions quoi deux des discussions de
vlad entre eux quoi ça extraordinaire
soit à 3,4 laddh men navarra n'aurais
pas fait ce coup oui mais navarre est il
si fort quoi il n'aurait pas fait non
mais mais là non médecins canadiens plus
ça peut très bien se passer n'est
possible bombe brune besoin d'un pion je
prends un café dames c'est 50 hockey
bijoux vite ce qu'on la barre est enfin
de toute façon savoir que ce dépôt je
vais aussi vite et ses 500 bons coups
malheureusement est ce que tu penses
qu'il a pu regarder b5 jeu séparé juste
par hasard tu dis qu'est ce que pourrait
jouer maxime et humer b side c'est des
fois le genre truc comme ça aux exams
sat et j'arrive aux exams tuvéri culture
et visant la nuque mais plus à pitre euh
ouais
en fait c'est pas un dépôt qui ont eu
l'idée mais un thé seconde on peut alors
lui tient en fait y associait ce set up
fais ci fais ça c'est précis vrai
d'ailleurs ce serait une très bonne
préparation je ne veux pas juste être
quelqu'un qui te quitte break it '
résiste leurs biens c'est là aussi
l'utilité femme quand on parlait hier de
naka qui avait un second temps qui est
21 50 lits l'utilité d'avoir un second
temps vous a parlé d ryazantsev l'écho
nayer vlad nilsen et celles intéressés
comme ce sont de très bons joueurs
d'échecs ils sont capables de comprendre
que d'après le stylet nouvelle pourrait
jouer p5 jusqu'à comme ça un éclair qua
non mais en fait tu dois faire les deux
tu dois faire mon ordi mais en fait
c'est bien d'avoir des mecs qui font
leur nid et toi tu respectes ton cerveau
tu dis tiens qu'est-ce que je jouerai
exposition qui ce qu'on pourrait ne
jouer que ce qui est humain et tu
réfléchis avec mon cerveau pas en train
de regarder ce que dit nordine et c'est
un problème parce que même moi quand je
regarde des lignes je leur dis là bien
sûr je regarde ce qu'il y ait que la
raison c'est donc le mans mais mais
c'est pas et du coup du coup avoir cette
double se faire ce double travail or dit
plus sur l'affection juste humaine c'est
excellent et c'est très difficile c'est
s'est ouvert qu'aux tout meilleurs
seconds en de premier choix et c'est
pour ça qu'on vous disait que la liste
des seconds qualité était très limité
parce que c'est
et c'est dur quoi c'est dur de faire sa
ba en fait c'est facile 6 antennes team
jir même sur les deux en fait oui j'arme
moi je fais de l'ordi où toi tu fais de
l'ordi et l'autre il se doit d'expliquer
ok je conservais des trucs et tu te
faire appliquer par l'ordi notamment
mais voilà mais en fait arrivé tout seul
à faire les deux s'est juste pas simple
du tout là c'est pour ça que c'est
ouvert a si peu de gens quoi d'être
capable de philosopher c'est du tout bon
faut 6 1 par les double double file a
des idées sans ordi c'est c'est des gens
comme ça qui sont un petit peu
exceptionnel travail de seconde en reste
exactement comme les échecs normes enfin
kiki qui est capable de faire des
parties vraiment parfaite on a bien vu
que dès qu'on sort du top 10 mondial
le gap est énorme il ya très peu de gens
au monde qui sont capables d'être
d'avoir un perfectionnisme et d'avoir un
niveau incroyable dans leur discipline
va second danser comme joueur du tennis
voir des chefs c'est une discipline à
part entière et il ya très peu de
personnes qui sont qui sont capables
d'avoir cette cette profondeur etienne
on est capable bien évidemment puisque
le joueur français est aussi etienne de
son côté mais les rues sont ses
préparateurs d'exception aussi de leur
côté est donc un coup comme des
ceintures veille sur un coup de toi un
coup de génie la même pu voir ça au
feeling non mais c'est bien il faut se
met dans la peau de l'adversaire et de
sentir son style de ce qu'est ce qui
peut jouer ou pas fab je pense que je
vais je vais le dire maintenant on va
pas c'est peut-être ça fait une heure
une heure de stream va peut-être passer
une petite minute de cube le monsieur là
public si tard là j'en profite pour
remercier à quelqu'un qui ses abonnés
tout à l'heure je crois avec twitch
prime c'était bon élève donc merci
d'avoir lâché ton prime on met la petite
pub petite respiration après dames c'est
ça qu'on est sorti de l'ouverture donc
donc bonjour je suis en réunion au
boulot je peux pas mettre le son vous
pouvez me dire comment elle s'en sort je
vais écrire
bon moi je veux j'ai pondu par l'image
damien navarra non mais j'ai fait ça
d'une petite montre dubitatif je préfère
comme la toile et avec les la bouche
quoi il dealait donc saluer un moyen de
voir la retransmission du match l'ouest
sur youtube sur la chaîne officielle de
la fidh tu peux avoir les images comment
une chose je pense qu est ce donc on est
dans le dur lénine 06 qui dit en mille
de loges ce n'est pas par rapport à quoi
il réagit il ya un ya un chat très animé
aujourd'hui un j'ai du mal à à tout
suivre vous êtes vraiment présent vous
êtes nombreux ça fait plaisir
le nord ouest de nice
c'est bien ça bouge ça bouge à regarder
avec combien de messages à la minute
c'est impressionnant
c'est impressionnant on n'a pas le temps
de mon avenir mais aucun espoir est ce
que dit lors ni leur dîme du blanc
qu'est ce qui se passe sur cavaliers
prend alors déjà ses eaux noires de
jouer donc c'est un petit peu dur de
jouer de quoi la fois mais de faire sur
qui les prends je crois qu'il y avait un
truc comme dam des cinq peut-être tourbe
et 8 pour jouer sur la colonne baissé il
n'y a pas de réfutation fait qu'il prend
c'était tout à fait jouable
c'était jouable il n'y a pas de
réputation mais on sent que les noirs
vont s'activer et c'est ce qu'on vous
dit c'est maxime joue pas correct il
cherche les chances pratiques et
cavaliers prend c'était là mais c'est
pas tomber 5e
ma position est déjà dur alors s'il peut
il veut faire juste fou prend bessat qui
a gardé son cavalier en c3 qui est très
bien placé donc il se dit ok tu vas
faire à 6 pour le protéger d'une bêtise
et maintenant j'envoie à 5
mais en réalité le pion b5 je m'en fiche
c'est ce que je dis n'est pas je crois
non même si on veut s'en prendre entre
un jour s'il traîne en force mais tu
veux pas aller contre jeu tout de suite
avec ton recentre la colonne b qui
s'ouvre et tu rentres nulle part on nous
dit b 4s que maxime aurait joué le p4
c'est peut-être un oui mais bouclé les
brigades je pense qu'elle valait 1 4
mais c'est pas idiot peut-être cavaliers
des 5 es tu maintiens ton plus envie
droit f2
d'ailleurs être deux et h5 c'est
peut-être une manière de continuer c'est
dur hein parce qu'en fait je vois pas
trop l'intérêt d'avoir amené le pion
jusqu'à des quatre ans en réalité non
mais non je me suis offert deux tours se
dire non mais j'y couffin je sais pas je
suis très confiant aujourd'hui la femme
j'ai pas toi mais moi je suis très
confiant
moi je te semble confiant je te sans eux
[Musique]
je te sens je sens la desesperado non
c'est non non ce wave je te sens je te
sont non bagués lsd syndrome grippal
non je te sens je te sont dans le dur la
fab bramont fanny vaché aller là les
mecs fabas et non je te sens tu te sens
dépité la non mais j'ai du mal à être en
ont joué à fond parce la position fait
peur voilà moi c'est nettement accrue
moi je dis ça je dis rien moi je sens
une mi-temps de synthés psg voûté mené
2-0 et a pris un carton rouge se dit bon
bon je quitte pas j'arrive jusqu'à la
fin quand même quoi
non mais on dit mais bon il doit te
donne envie de quitter le stade côté de
l'intérieur stade stade stade firminois
la cc puis un chaudron la ccs casseroles
et invite donc les amis tour et faire
des vidéos en fait sur synthé quoi les
amis on est franchement je ferais bien
mais franchement hostile je vais pas
faire je vais pas faire du mot en moins
bien
mais pour sainté normal c'est qu'on
devait faire à d'autres fermes et à huis
clos à titre conservatoire jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
mais donc nouvelle en soi qui nous sera
facile me le donner un ordre en 2048
alors mais y aura rien comment 28 ans il
y aura plus il y aura rien non mais j'en
ai marre c'est plus tranquille et fumer
ça va il craque des fumigènes qui
fusaient n'y a pas de mains il ya huit
morts 4 civils n 50 blessés ça va
laisser les cédantes mais puyi rien donc
je ne sais pas presse avec s'intéresse
internity venir mais je sais pas enfin
c'est chiant cette guerre totale entre
jeu vers le front à 100 c'était des gens
sûr de la partie de la nouvelle comptes
né paul ont rajouté du sang tu es la
mejor vidéo est en train d'abattre fable
quoi fab fabian taux qui va nous faire
ce qu'on appelle une petrossian quoi tu
vas en bar et si on va devoir baisser
petit à petit du siège puis on verra
plus qu'un morceau feront quoi dire
c'est que j'ai mon front très très
visible que sur les live je m'en fous
visible tout court dans la vie réelle je
veux dire mais mais là en plus comme la
came la pop star fait quand même très
attention parce que depuis quand ton
équipe référant à la permanence de
sainté on pourra discuter je suis pour
l'om tu vas donc j'en y tenir j'ai de la
marge
on suit la tape un peu le maire est noyé
manger gagnent la coupe d'europe
oui oui j'ai gagné là c'est déjà sympa
s'est ouverte vers les conditions on
s'en fout quand même à gagner le maple
masse très respectable mais en plus je
suis pas je suis pas vraiment mal je
mange en réalité je mange mon celui je
regarde vraiment plus les matches ça ça
m'intéresse puis en fait non pour le
coup c'est même ça joue bonsoir je
marque des points j'ai vu un match de la
saison je n'arrive pas à regarder le
seul match je me suis fait plaisir cette
année c'est c'est quand j'ai regardé
athlétique au barça le but de monsieur b
ce soir je crois c'est demain
demain il a été loyal variable ça c'est
des matchs que je peux regarder mais
honnêtement la ligue 1 après je regarde
du catch parfois le catch je vois pas
vraiment indifférent je préfère le catch
à la ligne en fait c'est un peu le même
truc mais c'est plus clair pour moi ce
qui se passe donc est nouvelle en
difficulté les gens qui parlent de
dévale d'ordi écouter on a fait le
résumé maxime en difficulté internet
joue au hockey donc attaque le 3 1 là
pour le court 2 mauvaise idée la
fourchette angers 3-1 donc plutôt ruff 2
août ou rage 3 une touche trop mais on
avait vu que roy f2 si tu as beaucoup
analysé tu sais qu'à vallée prend h4
n'est pas du tout on parle surtout
callas ou chromé 5
même pas une vraie menace tu perds mène
pas depuis en fait ouais tu doubles et
touré non mais c'est vraiment dur à
l'impression je sais pas je c'est pour
ça que ça c'est pas que je suis déprimé
déprimé mais j'ai du mal à être emballé
par la position noir qui juste assez
inquiétant tout après faut dire qu'avec
fab on a on a on a un problème commun
c'est que on aime bien quand les parties
gagnées sont propres en fait c'est vrai
factor mais la botte en touche
enfin là aujourd'hui on ferait elle
exception qua non mais jean rhein
l'expression mais faut dire qu'en oui je
préfère en général on est des joueurs un
peu ancienne école avec fable dont on
peut le dire tu as comme on parle un peu
tout et là on est des joueurs ancienne
école qui aime bien qu'ils aiment bien
les parties très propre donc en gros on
a on a du mal à s'emballer là évidemment
on à fond pourraient mieux aller moi je
suis vraiment pour qui la sauve mais en
fait ce qu'on aimerait bien fondamental
on dans le fond du fond du fond du fond
notre hub avec fabriquer rebelles il ya
une belle partie tu vois bien gris
chuken car le nesc pour la peine
non mais il fait des fois oui gerland
mais on voudrait qu'il le fasse là
aujourd'hui c'est bien bon mais là du
coup on n'a pas le choix il faut sauver
un maximum et demain fans de litres ou
grand rapide où n'importe quand peu
importe la méloine si ce week-end
j'avais partie propre connu pour spammer
g4 en fait j'essaie de le faire pour
jouer en partie longue ailleurs c'est un
problème c'est pour ça que c'était dur
mais en fait c'est enfin c'est une
frustration pour moi ne pas être capable
de le faire et du coup j'aime bien quand
je vois des gens qui sont capables de le
faire du coup mais là on va faire une
fois on fait toujours une exception
toute façon mais là d'autant plus que
c'est fallait j'ai envie de te dire si
l'on y compris mon nom mais si on gagne
un peu la ligue des champions comme
celle ci l'avait gagné là le match la
finale
combien de vacances à venir on prend bah
ouais non mais des fois même
alors on reparlera du bayern dont il est
éperdument manchester en 99 il aurait dû
gagner qu'un soin qui se prennent deux
buts coup sur coup
ok en sport ça arrive que des fois tu
mérites pas sur le contenu puis tu
gagnes et puis bah tu prends évidemment
ma maxime qui envoie la nouvelle il a
complètement raison de doutes ouais il a
raison non mais j'aime ce qu'il fait il
va il va craquer mais pau bas mais au
moins tu donnes les chances de craquer
c'est bien ce que fait le joueur
français fable le flore français qui
réagit le joueur français qui est là la
france la france n'est pas tombé fab
il saute dans la roue ouais il est il
est dans la roue mais d'ailleurs en fait
d'avancé 5 finalement bien placé pour
éviter les trucs sur cinq thibaut pinot
qui s'accrochent fab
puis nos pilotes thibaut pinot banshee
qui s'accroche
il est dans la roue il ne se laisse pas
distancer comme ça ok ce que un truc que
tu as envie de regagner leur dis parce
qu'en fait le tour huit coups de
l'artiste avant logique cavaliere
qu'as-tu contrôle des deux noms mais son
double et dans le même style
oui mais là tu veux te garder faut
prendre des cinq ans menace non mais non
mais aucun nom mais aussi les deux mais
pas juste fou j'ai deux pour le coup
c'est un peu de connerie parce qu'il ya
des français et des preuves à ta dam des
deux chocs et aucune autre coup le
contre je rêve très très vite mais du
coup le truc logique c'est de vite faire
car il ya quatre contrôles et des deux
menacées fou prend et met vite une tour
en d1 et continue avec h5 plus tard donc
soit quelques 4 normale soit fou 2 juste
unité tout retour bien ils disent n'est
pas la rampe et alès je sais pas j'ai
pas de voir les images je veux j'ai
donné mon avis j'essaie de faire du dha
lecture massif et du body language non
mais n'est pas le problème c'est quand
tu vois un contre un joueur comme toi ou
moi ça marche très très bien
fanon serait très énervé déjà qu'ils
foutent le bordel on aurait très peur de
se prendre un chip haut et c'est sûr
qu'on ferait une cave dans les quatre
cinq coups à venir ça c'est écrit mais
n'est pas le truc c'est que c'est aussi
ce genre de joueurs et peut-être qu'il
fait lui n'a pas peur de ça c'est ça qui
est un peu dommage
il a fait tourner à dire il se
tranquillisent bas j'ai pas le coup à
l'image
il vient de faire tourner un et là alors
dit que tout d'un coup ça va ya plus
aucun problème après p4 tour dit un des
quatre hommes c'est assez logique mais
canary bay va maintenant bab el kaddouri
tempo vient de jouer tempo c'est fini a
plu davantage quasiment mme bah voilà
enfin vous étiez tous en pls
moi le premier heureusement qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui est calme sur ce chat dans
ce live
enfin voilà n'ai pas fait de la merde
normal c'est bizarre pour des rames est
bon mais il a peu vécu il s'est planté
par contre c'est pas encore fait mais ok
au moins tu es très heureux c'est un
cavalier peut pas dégager de ces trois
de fête frein et le pion de icloud et tu
vas prendre deux heures parce que tu te
fais le visa visa catastrophe du coup du
coup du coup voilà et du coup mais capté
objet de prendre
il en fait maxime a joué b5 pour
argenteuil lecteur br 8 est ok il nous
faut tous partout et peut être gagner
barry du goût a complètement attendait
un très grave très grave trous et il
s'annonce complètement du coup ouais
c'est une énorme erreur
oui c'est catastrophique tour n'est pas
fou 2 qui avait eu lieu quatre c'était
vraiment fait un tour d un ça se voit
tout de suite si mauvais bah ça soit non
contre eux mais tu réfléchis à b4
tutorat tout d'enrichir leur et merci
merci pour le seul à tanger regard du
mec qui a seul parce que je vais pas ici
mais merci à sa draft qui assomme avec
le switch prime merci tonton
non mais vous étiez en sueur j'ai senti
qu'ils avaient craqué mais tour des ans
je ne voyais pas craquer aussi vite non
mais là c'est il portera la place donnée
aux flammes 3 mega propose ne tu penses
non mais lui je sais pas si tu vas faire
je dis juste que c'est pas si con parce
que tu sens que ça peut déraper une fois
que tu es président tu te prends ça une
fois en fait tu sais avec déjà deux
types en forme tu calculé que de la
merde et
le monde a raté les freins mais
peut-être que max ophuls pas si un
scénario comme ça arrive parce que tu te
dis bon ok c'est un cas pression c'est
très chaud mais en fait face on fera
mais je le batte un jour ou l'autre je
veux pas juste faire null null null
accepté et pleutre f1 façon tu dois
gagner un jour l'autre et ben pourquoi
pas mal non non mais là c'est vraiment à
ce niveau de la compétition c'est une
erreur quand même énorme
mais maxime il fait vraiment déjouer ses
adversaires tan dung ce trio sommes très
très grave incroyable c'est cesser moi
j'étais quand même confiant et je
pensais que max il va réussir à la tenir
mais un coup comme tour d un à ce niveau
là c'est wes et c'est vrai grosse gaffe
quoi donc dame prend adam prend b4
tomber vite damas trois il ya eu aussi
cette je continue à jouer tempo comme
antastique brûlures de rien quoi mais là
c'est joue pas c'est vraiment chaud déjà
tu peux commencer à envisager d'aller
bouffer h4 peut-être c'est moins grave
de faire attaquer parce que tu as vous
trouverez un autre front peut-être que
l'on sait du c5
ça c'est le style de maxime sativa c'est
un coût qui va faire parce que dans un
premier temps prendre les deux donc
force tu en prends et du coup il ya plus
le socle pour défendre cinq et une
boutade à mais ça peut être partout et
je sais pas ce que ça
mais ok ça tout paraît juste vraiment
tout peut arriver aux moments importants
ah bah ouais ça fait du bien autour d un
synthé paris ou prix ciao silva marque
deux buts contre son camp ont tout d'un
coup nous quoi tu dis où l'art n'est pas
sorti d'affaires roulement bon ça va
beaucoup mieux qu'à 2 case zéro deux
videurs disais hier qu'il ya plein de
joueurs qui veulent plus du tout joué
certaines in tellement even et domine
ouais mais c'est par là c'est quand même
étonnant parce qu'il avait vraiment
choper dans l'ouverture et en gros là
c'était pas une position si compliqué à
pour la finir et pour bien la jouer sur
10 coups oui c'est compliqué mais là il
fait quand même une erreur très
étonnante
je pense pas que j'aurais fait cette
erreur par exemple personne n'entend
normale après je suis quand même le
faire de tout faire mais
et je pense que ces genres de couteau d
un je m'en serais vraiment voulu la voir
jouer quoi baptisé de temps vouloir
c'est pas possible alors clio 4 6 je
pense qu'en bleach je joue au yoyo
quatre dents longues après tu peux
parfois psychoter bien on le sait c'est
un petit peu je suis un complétons débit
c'est une pop poursuit a fait après coup
mais méjean recalé aux quatre jeux c'est
vraiment paraît que maxime vu le niveau
de jeu de mam est née peau dans les
temps mais ils n'ont pas gagné il mérite
quand même largement plus qu y consommer
comme on a déjà dit un truc c'est sur un
match et sur un match tu sais jamais de
la saison qui compte objectivement quand
même ce serait plus logique qu'il y ait
quand même là non mais maxime maxime qui
est bon après vraiment dans les prépas
faut qu'il fasse quelque chose pour les
candidats parce que sa rencontre contre
des joueurs du calibre de nez peau de
de topalov et tout s'est passé par
contre s'il se fait avoir trois quatre
fois comme ça sur les candidats mais pas
besoin de 3,81 s'est fixé aux deux déjà
tu gagnes plus le tournoi et donc c'est
un fils deuxième au dernier
oui pour gagner il faut au moins plus de
pucerons donc si tu fais deux défaites
absolument qu'ils règlent ce problème
avec les noirs parce que ça contredit
glee rennes ou caruana ça va pas passer
vous faire tourner ça c'est sûr mais tu
vois c'est pour ça que le gap de maxime
là pour passer top 3 top 4 pour passer
la 4e 5e 4e place mondiale à la 3e 2e il
est quand même assez grands noms m'avait
dit peu après sur un rush mais un sur le
fond ce n'est pas si simple
parce que
ces voix on voit des qui joue contre un
mec hors du top 5 d'ailleurs c'est que
great choc qui réussit enfin le plus
faible qui a réussi à lui faire des
partis plus ou moins parfaite et à le
retenir c'est gris tout mais dès que tu
es sortie de grille tout qu'en fait ils
craquent tous vraiment de donc de ce qui
est quand même bon signe mais déjà par
la queue aux candidats efforts à faire
gaffe parce que des grilles chucky en
aura trois failles aura un gris tout
qu'un dépôt est indigne d'un pokémon
donc y en a que les bulletins de vote
c'est vrai
wen est parce qu ils ont l nakai bon
naka illescas monte à quoi de 1830
quasiment numéro deux mondial à royan
qui peut aussi fins et déjà d une autre
classe comme il faut dire vrai bon t'as
qu'à la justice et plus d'ouverture il a
pu motiver mais s'empêche pas le fond
oui et puis on a cas on peut en parler
de sa préparation
on va pas peut-être revenir dessus mais
bon même galette ans
les ventes sur les trente prochains
coups bon après faut pas qu'ils
contrôlent crack qua non mais en fait le
poids lors va déjà on souffle à fonder
déjà très confiante parce que c'est
tellement horrible que bon ben là c'est
cool mais on n'est peut-être pas mieux
objectivement mais c'est juste devenu
très chaud le roi f2 il va constatés
dans les courants d'air et et ça peut
vraiment bien le faire moi j -c le
moment c'est le moment de mettre une
petite pub aller au bout du suspens
ouais le suspense revient on est revenus
dans la partie tout d'un coup petite pub
n'attendez pas un handicap et du coup a
tout de suite la pub elle a tout de
suite pour moi je vais pas arraché du
beurre et n'est pas huilé son échiquier
nous y fait beau rêve web en question il
à elle un peu et un peu crac crac crac
ou nehmé mais on le dit il ya la
pression psychologique de maxime j'ai vu
aussi un truc passé dans les
commentaires c'est vrai que maxime a
déjà battu cinq fois n'est pas en partie
longues une épaule n'a jamais battu donc
il ya aussi un
un avantage psychologique pour pour le
joueur français
non là c'est en train de très bien se
passer dans l'ouverture il ya eu un
petit coup d'un petit coup de mou mais
pau a quand même très vite très vite
craqué bon maintenant
maintenant rien n'est fait dépôt n'est
pas perdant c'est plus la dynamique
mirta ce qui était mon entraîneur me
disait souvent que dans une partie est
un peu comme un match de boxe
celui qui mène ce n'est pas celui qui
mène aux points c'est celui qui vient de
mettre les derniers coups et là il se
trouve que maxime est bien lui mettre un
crochet du droit
ils viennent lui mettre un coup au
crochet du droit bien pensez donc
donc dans la la la la la position et a
minima égale
malgré l' avantage peut-être ordinateur
est ce que de dépôts et à mon avis c'est
même c'est même le joueur français qui a
un petit un petit avantage
on nous propose de faire f e d e f ou
prend 2,5 alors là le truc c'est que je
vais pas te faire f 35
je vais te faire tout reprendre des huit
intermédiaires ce qui va être assez
pénible que de passes à bien se passer
donc alors f-35 jouer et l'ordi qui
redonne un 73 pour le joueur russe
attention oh là là le contre craquage du
joueur français
qu'at-il vue sur des prend 1,5
l'ordinateur serait affole il redonne du
bon dieu a dit dur 1,75
je sais pas si c'est si grave mais en
tout cas c'est la première info la de
but en blanc convoi dames 8
bon il se calme un petit peu par la
suite l'ordinateur qui a du mal à
décider mais en tout cas
en tout cas c'était loin loin loin loin
d'être le coût optimal le coup que
recommander l'ordi c'était c5 et femmes
pensaient qu'ils allaient jouer ou dames
8 direct pour aller jouer pour du dams
et 6 c ou du cavalier prend h4 aussi un
pour jouer surtout reprend h quatre
duels prend 1,5 et venir peut-être joué
sur cette diagonale
c'était peut-être possible mais lève
prend 2,5 c'est pas le premier coup on
ne sait pas pour le moment c'est la
première première petite information
qu'on donne qu'on donne tout de suite
qu'on vient de voir mes dépens de cinq
dames 8 ça me paraît loin d'être si
clairement le joueur français qui joue à
mon avis correctement alors qu'est ce
qui se passe ici sur foot est roi il
aurait pas un petit fou prend 1,5 qui
rôde
c'est quoi le problème c'est que sur
pions prend là j'ai pu leur dire il n'y
aurait pas de bonnes découvertes
ah c'est peut-être ça le problème je
remets l'ordi pour vérifier mais je
crois pas qu'ils aient de bonnes
découvertes
ouais c'est ça y'a pas de découvertes
ici car et les h4 de a- à rien donc ça
voudrait dire qu'après des deux dames 8
fou des trois serait jouable avec l'idée
peut-être justement de se débarrasser de
ce cavalier de repartir avec le roi vert
2 par la suite peut-être de faire
je sais pas moi je sais pas j'ai pas
peut-être d'annoncer sa dame sait si ça
peut-être fou et 4 donc fabien qui
revient et qui va voir qui va voir en
direct est 3e 5
fabien qui essaye de mettre ces
écouteurs fabien quelques tee-shirts
vitrine fabien cas les écouteurs fabien
l'information c'est faux seins que gap
du joueur français
crevaison à l'arrière bien post point
bas je sais rien c'est quoi ces l'ordi
qui gueule parce que ça leur dit kigali
l'idée prend 2,5 mais en fait je peux
comprendre tu vas perdre et eux
qu'est-ce que faire d'autre oui mais
j'arrive à perdre un tempo avec la lame
et du coup bah maintenant peut-être fou
détroit est ok c'est pas si grave mais
on comprend bien que dans les variantes
tout à l'heure on s'activait beaucoup
plus avec les noirs aux quais n'ont rien
de quoi ces cinq sinon regardez ces cinq
dames à 3,5
bush regardez sa dame c'est bidon après
je sais pas dams et c'est peut-être en a
on peut avoir l'air de leurs ordis et
que ma mère va t on voit que ça ouvre
mais en fait est ce que dans l'échiquier
théodore fillon convainquions ça change
quoi ça change et ça change la colonne
c1 mais sachant de la colonne et fab ça
change que maintenant tu détruis ça ça
change
comment tu veux faire plus on prend qui
prend 2,3 fois ci notre tu fait tout
péter
ainsi c'est une idée dont on a parlé fab
si je te des excuses moi de 2,2 tonnes
de chaperonner
mais on en avait parlé déjà avant f4 de
secousses et 5 pour déstabiliser la
structure lautner donc c'est un coup
qu'on avait depuis longtemps et là
maintenant le truc c'est que le pion
c'est après des jeux je vais bien le
montrer en fait tant qu'on a ce
conflit-là le pion c'est peut intervenir
sur la structure blanche
mais dès qu'on fait un peu d eux le truc
c'est que le pion c'est peut plus
intervenir sur le trio de pions n'ont ni
sans permis mais bon ok mais gérant
comprend que c'est une erreur après fab
on est un peu obligé de mettre leur nid
et de faire du bien parce que nous
autres on voit m on va faire sans faute
à non étoiles
concert généreux avec l'ordi évidemment
je vais consacrer nord mais comment
comment comment non mais sans laure dit
comment tu vas tu vas commentaires on va
jamais rien ça ce qu'on peut puis les
poules mais oui mais tu auras pas
d'émotions tu vas pas sans fin ce ne
sera pas à condition d erreur ou pas les
mecs qui voit dix fois plus vite que
nous ils ont vu des variantes
nous on va avoir de la merde pendant
quatre heures qua non mais on va faire
que des ventes on donne des pièces en un
coup avant n'avait pas compris avant
n'avait pas compris puis à la fin j'ai
appartient en fait on n'a rien on essaye
de comprendre pourquoi avec l'ordi puis
ça permet de faire un peu d émotion dire
avaler les mieux il est moins bien c'est
ce qu'il va voir si et puis deux voilà
c'est leur dit qu'ils avaient laissé
leur dit qu'il nous permet de savoir un
peu ce qui se passe sinon
on n'y comprend rien là par exemple on
aurait mis combien de temps pour
comprendre ça bah en fait n'aurait
jamais plaint mais c'est sain qu'on peut
regarder mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que dans l'échiquier a mais je dis pas
le contraire
ok parce que là en fait tu ouvres quand
même plus ou moins on aura peut-être des
foins 5 à un moment à regarder pour les
blancs est ok pour l'instant là les
tours blancheton palier du jeu soient
connues mais peut-être la colonne des
[Musique]
avoirs non mais j'aime bien ne pas
m'être lors du camp s'est départi plus
simple et on le met moins mais quand
c'est des parties compliqué comme ça en
fait on est incapable de calculer ya
trop de trucs et on comprend rien quand
c'est des petits trucs stratégie comme
la partie contre dingoo quoi on peut
analyser sans même élan plus on a un
truc assez faible enfin on est
profondeur 20 fab gers est pas très fort
même mathieu au début il était plutôt
content puis après il s'agit d'un fouet
donné finalement non mais il dit quand
l'ordi est faible c'est pas mal ce que
ça évite de raconter juste n'importe
quoi pendant quatre heures ce que les
joueurs ce qu'on dit le voit où ils ont
pu le voir où ils ont pu le comprendre
mais c'est vrai que f d autant plus ses
5 îles à 10 ans leur dis oui par
ailleurs c'est hyper logique c'est 5 et
6 mai après bloody je calcule rien va
juge je vois que c'est un coup qu'il ya
une certaine logique après je sais pas
où mettre la gomme sur des français je
pense qu'il fait d'hommes dams est bon
notre statut sérologique oui mais voilà
tepa quatrième mondial mais le trx des
en-buts moi je joue pas la partie je
veux pas à des packs après mondial tu
commentes en même temps tu sais juste
que de visu en fait voilà moi je fais
toute vision ça m'a l'air jouable près
juste faux calculs concrètement quand
dans l'échiquier pas mais on aurait dû
se tromper on aurait pu faire tourner un
on aurait pu faire machin et tout mais
juste après la partition mais bien je me
sens plein mais si j'étais mieux alors
dit analyse après que j'ai vu tout
racheter j'étais complètement débile a
raté ses cinq j'aurais été assez
mais ça dépend si on compte faire après
en fait c'est quoi sont ils jamais ce
que je n'aime pas c'est que tu fais feu
dès le coup le plus logique et sûrs
réfléchit déjà au moins c'est peut-être
qu'il voulait faire un truc qu'il s'est
rendu compte qu'un truc horrible mégère
ça veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose à
oui quand tu viens de jouer un truc
comme f
avec f c'est impossible il y avait
découvert quand même pas envie de
regarder et que le mec te fait d un seul
coup et que tu réfléchis encore trois
quatre minutes c'est qu'il ya un truc
qui n'allait pas c'est sûr je sais pas
quoi non du coup il fait quoi 2008 comme
si vite c'est l'un ou l'autre
non mesdames huit ans fait suite au pire
il ya déjà fois ci c'est tu perd 1,8 et
a juste donné fois-ci de cadeaux je pas
pourquoi pas quarante juste non mais
c'est pas obligé c'est juste pour dire
donc tu dois les dames eu vite fait de
votre choix ok ce que face au problème
c'est que fouquereau 5 simplment c'est
ce que je regardais quand ai parlé avec
le petit café je regardais juste fou des
trois mois un petit coup de
développement s'étaient pas couleur dit
là pour la peine et je regardais juste
j'ai allumé leur dit après j'ai vérifié
pour prend 1,5 après 5 ya pas de
découverte
non mais en fait je n'ai pas est ce
qu'on vend des trous où on g2 pour
contre le 6 mai après je fais mon
intuition ce que je voulais me donner la
possibilité de bouffer le truc et je
m'étais dit dames 8 fou des trois dames
c'est si j'aurai toujours fougueux 4 oui
mais du coup comme une actrice et tu
constates acquis et 3b de même en fait
je voulais prendre ici dans ces cas là
mais c'est vrai que peut-être
ouais c'est de la merde l'aller les
pions sont trop à tabac jeux mon bâton
rouge et deux là ils hayatou qui attaque
et pour les patrons de l'atome veine
quoi david freel chez ben c'est comme ça
bon ça reste très compliqué il ya moyen
de faire 40 mille erreur encore juste
pour le coup si tu cherche encore un
levier tâche sujets sains mais ça
commence à me faire peur j'ai passé
comme ça ouais ouais ouais ouais
- moins dynamique que ce serait plus
latrines les calculs ne sont pas bons
maxime camatchy partie partir en jeu et
les joueurs les joueurs dit mais souvent
de bonnes idées ces dames le sacre d'un
programme qui allait prendre double
attaque sur cinq est b-29 il opte ici
j'avais en ce lundi
pourquoi alors bride le rappeler parce
que prise prise
ah oui mais ça ça va pour les blancs
regarde la structure faisait quatre ans
qu'il tord des oeufs
c'est peut-être commencé en fait le
point c'est qui je vais essayer
d'oublier ces bons est un petit rat
concrète on dit mais je veux pas jouer
ce à quoi à fab qui nous lâchent une
info fabien libye zewski lâché une info
les amis chefs aux deux femmes hommes et
femmes c'est vrai que c'est ça en fait
le problème tu as tout compris
ah oui c'est tout c'est bien ça en fait
l'erreur c'est qu'en fait il s'est dit
ça il s'est dit je fais dames cette
prise prise double à l'otage et je
récupère un ballon et de là bas et donc
du coup il a fait d'aveux 8 du coût mais
ok mais ça contrecoeur et je pense donc
fiers de votre leader c6 à moins que les
trois soient jouables et dames c'est ici
un truc qui va pas mais de loin
j'éviterais de ceux ci seraient donc il
a raté ça avec ça explique qu'il ait
repris 4 minutes 30 pour jouer 6 minutes
30 sinon c'est inexplicable mais pas les
joueurs qu'ils font quand même des
erreurs énormes et l'a vendu stressant
parce que ça fait trop de trucs moi
c'est le stress des deux ans des années
pour le placer c'est partir en jeu les
deux joueurs bon goût pour le coup du
coup toujours mais ouais bon mais la
pollution reste compliqué
tu l'as jamais puis kg 5 et tu vas te
faire ouvrir non non non mais blanc ce
qui dope cherche à faire c'est leur
développement
jean rouger 2b 3 par exemple vous tordez
fou j'ai deux tours des deux tours
d'avancé juste toujours pas finie
philippe stores h4 en verre etc
mais les noirs en fait on voit pas de
plan c'est ça mon problème et on n'a
rien de plus donc on vous dit que
peut-être même temps retrouvé de la
finalité perdante
ce c'est possible aussi bien passé tu
t'en fait d'amos est du coup marche très
mal et retour 17 40
c'est horrible en fait là c'est déjà un
truc tu peux juste regarder passer les
voitures gardent vite fait tu dis ok
j'ai ça c'est bon je regarde autre chose
à autre chose et en fait t'as pris comme
acquis un truc que tu auras des vitrines
peuple quand tu regardes un peu plus
concrètement ce qui se passe c'est pas
du tout à qui bon mais n'est peau est
pas à l'abri d'un coup comme tours
d'essais de phase i/iia prix comme haïti
que la tour était protégé pas de chance
non mais je sais pas vu qui vu le nombre
de gav qu'ils ont faite peut avoir peur
de fou prend 1,5 raté un truc c'est ce
genre de partie quand tu commences à mal
calculé de façon tu l'as dit tout à
l'heure fab tu te mets à temps son côté
après là les deux joueurs ont fait des
erreurs de calcul donc les deux joueurs
sont à son stress clairement et pour le
couturier demande de l'ordi jeunes noirs
qui peuvent être surtout pour des trois
phases il trouve que dams et si c'est
pas si fort parce que eux quatre dom b6
on avait dit il ya quatre défend to
defend de 3 3 heures seulement et défont
b2 et attaque la dame nature car ayem vl
mais bon je pense pas qu'il 20 mai que
les nouvelles qui rebondit non plus
non mais ça j'y crois pas pareil jouera
pas ça non mais du coup c'est pour ça
que françois fougeron parce que moi je
vais pas me taper 600 m 3 parfois tu te
tapes adoubé 6 soit tu continues à
pousser et cavia 4 du coût écologique
ils font fi de faiblesse
mon vol est peut-être aurait joué au
foot est roi mais ça me parait dur de
voir ça jusque là
d'un seul coup débile mais clairement ça
se regarde et ben oui c'est ce qu'ils
pensaient mais du coup il se trouve que
ça va pas salaire à ses fans c'est pas
du dos des bills ryan c'est juste que
bienvenu s'avère bien est en fait un
vrai marche pas mais bon voilà je pense
ça marche pas maria robin et robin side
sait qui est qui et c'est sami qui écrit
les articles pour nous sur une chaise
comme il n'y a plus une seule rupture de
pions pour les noirs à part un
hypothétique g5 et la position des tests
pas réduire améliorée ouais y'a que la
dame qui pourrait arriver là mais c'est
vrai que foulée de sa coupe
sa coupe l'herbe sous le pied de la dame
quelque part elle se fait focaliser non
c'est marrant pas non mais c'est saint
seiya que j'ai cinq ce qu'on disait
comme une teneur comment au tueur
possible après peut-être du tarif 7 pour
aller jouer pour cavaliers prend mais
c'est possible de même un avocat lieu de
quoi tu sécurisé besoin du tout sécurisé
pas trop donc sur les recettes faut
quand même trouver un coup très concret
là pour les blancs faudra je crois c'est
possible
mais si je te prends quand même là je
veux cavaliers h4 et dames f2 après ils
te bouffe et là je tombe par des pions
comme ça on est sans ordi de nouveau
donc
on souffre un peu ouais bon il ya qu une
option peut-être pas si on écrivait le 4
pour défendre at the ice tu bouffes tu
bouffes de la dame aux camélias b2 qui
tombe
ouais donc tu vas pas ben ouais ce que
et au pire tu auras des mêmes des car
elle craint si jamais ça tournait mal
pour les mêmes décarie l'abc ce qu'ils
peuvent
rodez où des cavaliers g5 pour aller
taper aussi soit ok et si on prend et
5.5 je pense qu'on peut prendre parce
que découvertes ont mangé il ya plus d
chaque là tu peux pour me reprend un peu
non oui ma jeune tu peux pas aller assez
en l'air non mais reprend échec
ah oui en plus sur échec n'a jamais
vraiment eu peur de nous stopper tout de
suite sur des clayettes 6 contre échec à
oui oui oui
enfin fin du débat mais la jeune femme
il a fait bouger de le coup de femmes
voilées mehmedi toujours en lice non non
il éliminé depuis très longtemps nommé
en gros cette partie déjà assez décider
si max gagne-pain cette partie ce match
il est qualifié on n'a pas fini pour les
conduisent à s'échouer
cousineau logique sûrement clous des 3
et plus d'après les ordis mai mais on
n'a pas envie côté blanc va arriver là
d'avancé 6 b6 et s'activer c'est très
logique mais la nef c'est toi est ce qui
est autre chose que quelques 4 du
couffin rouge ce sont quelque 4 et un
problème de l'heure rien de trop claude
kb24 il dit très bien dit bien présent a
juste une petite bonne nouvelle qui peut
être utile c'est que même signer pour
prendre point de bonus
il y aura quand même besoin de gagner la
finale oui donc ça veut dire que si on
fait signer poids et prix poindre us
contre galles fanja sais pas c'est
anecdotique
les points de bonus un quoi en cas de
victoire avec point de bonus y passer il
passa le père de finale à noter quand
même que comme on est toujours chauvin
et on est les premiers à l'être mais il
y aura un truc assez injuste 6ème ciné
pause qualifié pas c'est qu'en fait s'il
gagne ce match ça ici c'est maxime qui
se qualifie avec une défaite 2 n'est pas
parce qu en fait née pour gagner autant
de matches que maxime ah oui ça arrive
et ça vire lienemann il a peu fait des
bonus où il n'a pas fait les bonus et du
coup il aurait une victoire en tournoi à
une finale et une défaite au premier
tour maxime aurait deux demi finale une
finale donc les deux finales ça nul
en fait pour faire deux demi finale ou
gagner un tournoi faut gagner autant de
matches et du coup on verrait que le
petit problème de calcul danser dans ces
tournois c'est que ok tu peux pas donner
enfin tu dois te fais quand même plus de
valeur à une victoire en tournoi si tu
as gagné autant de matches c'est
forcément plus dur de gagner demi
finales finale que gagner deux fois
premier et deuxième tours mais non mais
les bonus
non mais gère ça joue en notre faveur on
va rien dire mais géré comme on est
toujours là chagriné parce que quand ça
joue pas notre faveur pour la wild card
le machin et tout ça on est toujours là
tu vois et dire oui le truc est mal fait
tout ça bon là ce serait entre
guillemets mal fait en notre faveur on
prend et tant mieux mais je veux juste
dire par là que voilà faut être aussi
objectif quand il peut y avoir des des
règlements qui nous avantage très
clairement et là pour la peine c'est le
cas mais n'est pas perdu au premier tour
oui mais il aurait gagné autant de
matches
certes c'est comme si tu fais deux fois
demi finale de grand chelem est un mec
qui gagne le tournoi
pari gagné à droite grand chelem c'est
2000 points atp et faire une demi finale
c'est 600 points fasquelle normal que
gagner une fois ça rapporte
plus que deux demi finales surtout quand
il ya que deux tours pour y arriver soit
je pensais quand même tous d'accord mais
mais bon enfin c'est juste pour dire que
lhasa nous favorisent et c'est tant
mieux mais je voulais quand même le
signal capté d'accord ou ou pas oui non
mais après ils ont voulu valoriser les
points de bonus
peut-être qu'il est maurice trop
d'ailleurs par rapport au point un guide
interne en a peut-être que un demi point
de bonus par exemple c'était je sais pas
ok saverin fois qu'ils font ce format
c'est intéressant parce que bon on a des
matches à élimination directe ya du pour
et du contre mais mais tout n'est pas
encore parfait effectivement amicales
comme il dit le règlement a pas changé
en cours de route s'était fait à
l'avancé aux nîmois bubble je suis 100%
d'accord avec ça je dis pas ça jeudi le
règlement effet à l'avance pour ça et
c'est tant mieux et maxime peut se
qualifier comme ça et c'est génial mais
du coup faut pas venir me dire le
règlement de la wild card marche pas
parce que le règlement de la wild card
c'est la fédération russe qui choisit
parmi les joueurs éligibles qui prennent
donc le règlement était écrit pareil
avant donc voila quand le règlement est
en notre faveur
on prend quand il y en a deux défaveur
on l'acceptent quoi c'était juste pour
ça on va tous on prend tout ce qui à la
fin c'est à dire on fait pas les lois et
donc pour en revenir à position après
fugier de du coup qu'est ce qu'on peut
jouer créneau est ce que h6 pour faire
j'ai cinq mois je reste confiant juste
pour rebondir moi je reste confiant
c'est juste parce que je vois je voulais
je voulais parler de ça c'est marrant
robin ça qui aurait pu avoir un c'est en
marans ikaria qui n'était encore top 10
mondial et était allé en finale contre
les pots et le ru intérêt à perdre pour
koné push up le ticket pas le retrouver
dans la lutte pour la wild card
mais bonjour la situation mère est
marrant euros b'inside le cas de figure
que tu nous que tu nous proposes non on
voit que à boukari qui influeront dans
le top 10 mondial
mais il n'est pas sûr l'année donc de
300 questions à la justice alors jules
qui demande qu'on me propose nul drouot
aille aux fleurs d'euros ou un petit
regard mais ouais je te l'imposent passe
je te je te propose pas je te le dis
quoi bon du coup ah ouais tu lis cela ça
fait bien donc ça juste voir score avant
que le rni sur 1,6 il te refais cailloux
4 peu d'autres way avec idées sur gt5 de
partir pour alger alger prendre bêtement
bah oui c'est ça qu'est le 4 c'est
chiant ce qu'ils gardent en tête avec la
repenser sa bonne case
il fallait faire un lieu de tours a déjà
donc oui là on
il est là au mieux de ses pions et ils
ont trouvé une sorte de deux pêcheurs de
la quatrième manche il fait belle équipe
avec les pions parce qu'il est sur blanc
donc il joue sur noir et avec les pions
sur noir en fait il restait une vraie
pia vrai quoi c'est ça [ __ ] fou qui
peut ouais bah écoutes je sais pas je
trouve pas de candidat est ce qu on vous
arrache minutes dans l'allier caillou
quatre dames cécile pas c'est peut-être
pas idiot ça comme ça on a vidé les
cuves six échecs quoi bon après on
essaie de s'activer comme on peut et du
coup avec les blancs tu fais quoi jean
sirois chute c'est quoi ton id avec les
blancs parce qu'on n'arrivait pas de
cadeau bien de faire ça faisait six
tours d2 que j'aime bien c'est que je
ferai 1er mai vient de rendre le comment
ça tu vois là mais mesdames c'est simple
ok ça je comprends
oui ça à plat tu veux jouer le plus en
plus maintenant bah oui mais le problème
en fait c'est pion de plus mes
meilleures structures e6 très faible
parce que le case blanche qui allait
prendre fin sous ces cas ça va arriver
ouais ben trop de problème quoi cette
finale c'est pas qu un pion de plus en
fait c'est non plus avec bénéfices soit
trop de blesme pro dans tes propos
voilà ouais non ça marche pas si ben je
sais pas en fait c'est relou nous voilà
on nous propose faut prendre cinq ont
dit plusieurs 27 minutes côté français
je commence à être fait tu sais pourquoi
je n'étais pas inquiet de tallard parce
que je m'étais dit avant tout raté un
niveau va déconner un moment donné ça va
aller on vas tu as ça m'inquiétait pas
laisser le scénario andré keynes et le
scénario c'est comme d'hab le mec va
déconner max va s'en sortir mais en fait
généralement quand l'autre déconne max
ne donne pas hélas le fait que max et
contre déconner ça m'inquiète vraiment
c'est plus ça qui m'inquiète c'est que
je sens mon mac c'est un peu tu vois je
sens max pas au max quoi les jeux de
mots et l'humour
les jeux de mots laids et que plus fou
prend 2 à 1 que le joueur français qui
envoie fable maxi envoie all-in
mais là c'est du bluff pour la peine
vraiment comprendre oui voilà est ok et
quoi mais en fait ok il a juste regarder
tous les coups normaux
mesdames machin je sais pas ce qu'on a
regardé ça va et donc il tente alors
attends globaux pas technique f-35 et
prend hk 3 juin il a dû regarder la
ligne par assez logique mais voyons
étrangers de capio 6e 4 campbell cindy
les tours de notre dame 3 qui soit tu
reviens de loin quand on est très bien
sorti ok alors
non mais attends est-ce que ses forces
aient déjà avant parce que là on est
dans cette position qu'il prend des
princes 4 2 que juste pour venir
on a appris en cinq découvertes bon ok
roger un jeu bien jailli projet de donc
et déjà petite pause est-ce que qui a
lieu quatre par exemple 500 kg de
l'attraper en fait ok mais je fais dame
c6 quand même mais déjà g km
à part ça c'est moche parce que tu veux
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de casse pour
le cavalier est une menace dames cette
dame j'ai cette pâte mois août ont
franchi mais en fait j'aime pas de vraie
menace non pour les nommer trois quelque
part mais bon je suis venu dire il est
là tuez asmat direct enfin il a fait
reprendre cinq tempo cavalière du sport
orange est obligé qu'il est probable à
votre nom le fan posthume enfin que le
4e tour regarde et je suis ouais je
pense abandon c'est juste avant dont les
amis on va encore perdre en demi wuala
j'ai presque envie de faire une story
snap chaptelat mais justement on a perdu
contre des perdus bon allez faut qu'il
peut faire reprendre les deux hommes ces
six échecs qui l'aï ratée et encore même
là est ce que ça donne en fait juste
pour le savoir avec leur nez je veux pas
le savoir tant des machines désolé
infâme il répété moi j'ai tout dit aux
quatre vingt un jeu de paume et vergers
trois potes sais pas si con pour coup ci
c'est qu'à l'étranger 2 et 1 400 sa
marche encore un mirage 1 c'est beaucoup
plus logique puisqu'ils roger 3 tu dois
aussi option qui est cinq échecs
bon après tu as le droit de cacher je
sais pas mais moi j'ai un tempo bien sûr
je me sens là je me sens je me sens pas
bien la femme leucate aude genre truc
qui vaudra un [ __ ] mais qui de
services hyper j'ai envie de casser un
truc chez casbah j'ai pensé au téléphone
mais put ainsi fait cavalier 4 je
balance un truc par terre j'en ai j'en
ai marre là je sais pas quoi balancé par
contre j'aurai je vais avoir la tâche
les yeux il va le faire le con il va
faire cavalier quatre coins du fou dont
on invoquait des esprits non mais bon on
peut par perdre une [ __ ] de
demi-finale en 1h50 fav géré au bout
d'un moment enfin je veux dire y'en a
marre quoi il y en a marre non mecelec
quantième fois dans l'année qu'on voit
ça en fait
mais je sais pas non mais j'y rencontre
contre eux radjabov contre machin contre
tous la même si la gagne de toute façon
cirque après 1h50 palmarès c'est perdre
en deux coups quoi même s'ils venaient à
gagner charrecey c'est quand même encore
du temps il a fait non mais ça fait
chier ça fait chier fab
j'ai balancé le casier même pas pensé tu
vois ça m'a énervé mais j'ai un truc qui
est parti quand je vois pas en photo ce
que tu voyages gasquet parti quoi
d'autre j'entends bien vos enfants de
plus normé sac
non mais je vais faire ça va partir sur
redtube la la la la demi-finale quoi je
vais même pas laisser ça sur youtube
c'est n'importe quoi tant de victimes
boycott
il tente sa chance ouais non mais bon
mais ok mais en fait même s'ils gagnent
pas en fait là ça me fasse ça m'a énervé
quoi cela c'est encore une partie parti
de merde quoi
ok ou encore demander un peu de pression
au blanc s'est rendu à damas prendrait
peut-être amen je sais pas où vous
arrivez même demande à lui dit de faire
la miniature et mme bello candidature
afin de leur talent mans j'y crois après
il pourra perdre contre navarra en
finale
peinture on espérer une défaite de n'est
pas en finale contre nabarra afin qu on
va on va vraiment rester là les années
20 bon la partie est hyper même que là
ça va aller les amis jusque là où on
veut pas oublier qu'il ya une partie
retour oui après savait que contre mam
et ma mère effet complètement de la mer
de retour et maxime était remonté faut
pas non plus la faune il vendra beaux
jours sont à voir que dit il semble tous
les espoirs
après je veux dire s'il ya défaite
aujourd'hui c'est mal parti
hélas
ouais bon ciné peau ne décide de push le
tempo qui affligent en un quart d'heure
ici il va être une suite précise qu'elle
n'est pas encore fini fini mais juste
c'est juste le scénario déjà qui
m'énerve en fait serait pas une quarante
mille fois il y en a marre au bout d'un
moment enfin il passe quand même
complètement à côté de la partie fable
enfin on va se parler honnêtement entre
gens sérieux général a enfin faut
arrêter de venir me dire dans le chatt
ya pas de prime de pression maxime tient
la pression machin moi je dis depuis le
début quand il ya la pression qui est
trop grande il la tient pas il la tient
jusqu à certaines doses il ya une dose
de pression qui n'arrivent plus à tenir
faut arrêter de manière inverse c'est
c'est le cas fab web on s'asseoit de vie
on ne peut pas venir la maire de
bagnères maxime c'est un suspect à la
pression il est super calme il rigole
ouais ok mais mais
et tu vois mais je veux pas que les gens
me prennent ça comme une critique de
maxou quoi moi non plus je la tiendrais
pas la pression on est bien d'accord
mais genre il ya un vrai problème quoi
faut pas faire la stratégie de
l'autruche il ya un vrai problème
fomen défaut le regarder en face il y
est ça peut pas arriver à chaque fois au
bout d'un moment c'est la quatrième demi
finale c'est la quatrième fois bungert
c'est ok des fois ils attirent des fois
il retient pas mais quand il est
vraiment devant l'enjeu qui peut se
qualifier il te fait une partie mais il
te fais jamais départi de ce niveau là
toute l'année c'est un champion 200 g de
haricots verts le soir est question
juste comme ça soit position chèque lors
des dix tours c1 c'est logique tout
reprendre et de me prendre vite reprend
g22 md5 ok c'est pas si n'êtes pas ok et
ont peu embrouillée lorsque tu un
logique atteinte à des droits les deux
dames des 5 cm est en brouille un peu du
cloud fait 2.5 je sais pas et je savais
qu objectivement serait pas là et la
dame cinq dames des quatre mêmes noms
mais je dis ok enfin ouais tu peux faire
bout et on sait pas si mac et protiva de
boîte mais ok c'est encore on y croit
mais qui l'entourent c'est un fait je
peux comprendre c'est évident mais c'est
juste une question d'âme b5 c'est
pourquoi ces jeunes coup que je
regardais adams est comme ça qui a pas
d'échec en fait et tour des sept
meilleurs des cas 1600 non non non
mesdames un machin oui oui mais j'arrive
d'après des médecins cnom pour ces dames
des soins dans cette tour 17 km 6 à ça
tu veux excuser ou bien trop de choses
dans ma game on s'y fait horreur c'est
définitivement fini
il prendra vite c'est foutu mais
mais que peut faire mais il peut encore
craqué une épaule mais bon ça changera
pas le diagnostic mais peut-être que le
diagnostic
on m'a il dit est il est comme ça et
qu'en fait c'est un miracle que tu te
qualifies une fois les gnostiques est
parti mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
réfléchissent toujours je suis pas venir
la fin c'est le moment c'est mon
important pour lui il joue pas tembo et
enfin voilà peut-être craquer mais je
veux pas qu'on te voit pas sur sa robe
est en gros c'est un blitz tu veux juste
sauter sur tout reprend 2,8
si tu prends ton temps tu fais tes coups
candidats dont on prend des buts
clairement coup candidat mais bouger la
toux rauque et airois pranger 2 c'est
aussi candidat mais ça recommence à
ghadames c6 et compagnie mais donc ça
arrive tellement souvent gamme c6 soit
chiant dentelée linke en fait pour ça te
vient forcément cerveau est ce que je
dois tu viennes an ferme et une v4 donc
des cavaliers à six qui ont autant plus
un ça reste une menace ont dit ces
sources et 1c intro annoncé vraiment
trois hommes une rigole failli voilà
j'ai plus de second degré j'ai plus un
fable à là je suis à ces teams premier
degré voilà je n'en peux plus
désolé les mecs là ça me non mais en
plus sur moi je suis vraiment toute
l'année coiffant je suis personne du
monde qui suit le bus est parti de m
vertu à un moment donné tu as ce que
j'expliquais dans un live fait plus
c'était à coup du monde quoi tu as un
genre de lien émotionnel qui se créent
tue pas c'est inexplicable et tu te dis
oui bon ok là il va y arriver fin tu
suis quand même ça à tous tout au long
de l'année
tu fais 40 millions de stream tu
t'organises tes journées par rapport aux
trucs de mvl tu veux dire on y fait un
peu partie de ta vie quelque part est en
fait le revoir se faire éliminer la com
ça c'est tu vois sur ces cas là il n'est
pas encore éliminé kouamé voir voir ce
scénario pourri qui se disent heureux
pas ouais franchement ça me fait chier
alors tu donnes libres pourquoi pour ce
n'est pas que je trouve qu'ici c'est
bien l'histoire prend des huit dames
prandelli tu as pu en prendre six gp la
dernière peut être comment ça se passe
en f2 ok ça tu veux seront pas laissés
faire pas tu peux tu peux rater ça comme
ces deux matches à ok perpète bah écoute
un truc comme ça on prend quoi ben quoi
parce qu'ils réfléchissent et tu
réfléchis en fait tu veux aller au bout
des ventes
il peut faire il calcule bien des
bouquins et si infléchi va pas sauter
sur premier coup qui voit donc il fait
ses études à tous ok sinon c'est tant
mieux non mais bon après si mal fini
encore à la finale donné peau il a vu il
a montré qu'il était pas en super forme
qui craqua des tout il peut aussi craqué
contre x y ou navarra en finale honneur
ce qui se passe quoi la chaîne
j'espère que c'est oui qui va passer
quand même ok et deuxième truc on
n'oublie pas une partie demain dans tous
les cas winants il peut remonter il peut
remonter c'est vrai
on va avoir un petit peu craqué il peut
craquer il peut craquer craquer mais bon
là en rouille
pour cette partie seuls quatre yachts a
pu ton destin entre les mains des
banques que on dit laférois pranger 2 ou
pas ok mon encore une chance bazire que
les gens lisent écrivent des trucs
faciles à jouer ou pas ni pau ne regarde
pas la casse c'est un espace qui la
regardent pas qu'ils pensent pas c'est
surtout la carte sis il faut pas trop
qui regarde là j'ai du mal j'ai du mal à
lâcher des infos là c'est les français
en sueur mais bon moi c'est senna qui on
est ce qu'on fait même si vos candidats
je vois pas dans quel monde ça va bien
se passer quoi on verra quelque chose en
son temps
mais peut-il trempé son roi dans son
café à sa technique de deux cornes et
toast à toucher une pièce et que mal à
jouer tu fais mine de rien tu crois que
c'est à cuillères en fête et de les
rentrer dans ton café c'est très
intéressant comme technique
c'est juste un creux de quoi la
technique un mec ce soir y aussi ça
passe et je sais qu'à prendre pour jouer
le truc et puis tu le prends un écran
bien battus cette pièce fait moi je m'en
fous as-tu pensé une touillette mais tu
as touché mais il faudra pas rater quand
on arrive pierre intention de jouer au
hockey il ya eu intention une fillette
c'est quoi ce mec dégueulasse qui
maintient ou quoi mais un truc où tu as
des centaines de genre comme une hormone
dessus qui ont malmené après tu fais
sans qu'il s'en est pas rendu compte en
fait il veut attention pas c'est que ce
facteur x ou pour une bouille est
fréquent de travail mais c'est une
histoire de grand chemin que je crois
mais bien fade ok si tel adversaire et
que j'étais en train de te balader que
tu le vois pas bon ben blaque tout son
truc il tente un truc mais si tu es
assis en face tu vois qu'il prend la
pièce qui valent à bouger et qui voit là
couzier qui vont s'atteler sans gaieté
mais non mais je crois que ça me ferait
complètement lucide et bien si on fait
ça mais on va pas bien enfin je vois que
je me prend pour un con japon et
révélation de ce prix là c'est plus dans
le dans le fond que tu as et je vois
qu'avec vos cheveux sapiens et a touché
c'est ce que voulait si vous jouez
contre favre entourage voulait le faire
tilt
enfin après si vous jouez votre pièce
pleine de cafés
ça me va en fait mais si vous ne faites
le coût d'achat non non non non
tu vas y dis sur trois disques pouvoir
en gagner même pour né pas oui mais bon
il y aura un petit moment de
d'incertitude bon enfin en attendant ce
cas une belle journée pour mettre une
pub bat toujours n'est pas nouvelle
journée pour les clubs là les petites
pages de pub on va récupérer
il faut faire vendre a lancé la pub la
publicit adha
nanga fab bon écoute on va voir là c'est
difficile de dire quoi que ce soit à
position est perdante
on essaye de d'espérer qui s'offrent
c'est ça mais bon quoi dire coisy khabar
prix quoique cunego se trompe c'est tout
ce qu'on peut espérer un c'est tout ce
qu'on peut espérer au c'est chiant de
notre grand maître réclament comme ça
ludique de l'orge qui espère car il y
avait six échecs pour le père pète
oui bah en fait c'est notre meilleur
espoir naquit en ski en revanche pour
passer la partie en rapide
en fait j'ai eu des gaffes compter une
bonne prépa de dépôt qui après à café
mbella contre gaffé et là on en est là
donc
mais poussant l'amoureux de la case f6
mais peut-être qu'ils regardent tf6
échec et qui va se planter
grâce à sa huppe avait en fait le truc
c'est que maxime était déjà mal après
l'ouverture donc en fait les gars se
sont annulées et puis il a gardé son
désavantage quoi d'autre part moi ils
regardent cavaliers si ça veut dire oui
mais on regarde tout le temps de
regarder après je fais car il y avait
six femmes ce serait incroyable non ah
ouais bah en fait ce serait un beat rien
d'incroyable c'est logique puisque tu es
pauvre et de voir le père pète c'est pas
non plus un tu fais des détours et tout
mais si tu passes un quart d'heure sur
le coup non voilà ça devient sage et
bien ça devient compliqué fab
là j'en profite aussi pour jan boubli
n'hésitez pas à mettre à mettre un petit
polo sur la chaîne un petit pouce bleu
et un abonnement sur youtube si vous
souhaitez suivre la chaîne vitrine sur
youtube vous faut aussi la trouver sur
tweets je vous avais lien juste en
dessous avec les streamer ya aussi
d'ailleurs et moselle qui a sa chaîne
vous pouvez suivre donc j'en profite
pour faire un peu cette pub ya aussi les
leçons qui sont sortis en français sur
trois points comme si vous avez un
abonnement diamant vous avez toutes les
leçons
de la série le sont enfin les 125
première leçon qui ont été traduites
avec des exercices donc c'est excellent
pour progresser de débutants jusqu'à
1500 1600 est lourd et il a à jouer
non il n'a pas joué donc n'hésitez pas
si vous voulez faire un tour pour pour
regarder dans une question qui est rien
à voir mais est ce que vous savez
comment transformer une photo juste
normal pour avec le téléphone un truc
pour un pdf
je ne sais pas a dit les gars je n'en ai
pour vous aider c'est plus efficace de
balancer le switch problème sur chaise
comme fr ou sur lui ce qu'ils veulent et
2 ça va en fait ça dépend
bon ça va en fait les deux cas de figure
ferons donc comme comme tu préfères le
ps points comme donc j'irai voir merci
alors je regarde plus la bonne partie du
jeu la ferme et non mais oui navarra ça
semble faire nul mais ce sera
extraordinaire quand même qui est une
finale une petite faute à baralle quoi
que ce soit à fond derrière nava navarra
qui nous sauve et qu'ils nous envoient
aux candidats en fait ce serait
peut-être le plus beau scénario n'est ce
pas pilote on jubile vrai nom louis
navarre a tué d'un génie nous avons
sous-estimé ça extraordinaire
ce serait faux
c'est pas impossible mais c'est vrai que
ça se passe différemment en tout cas ce
serait étonnant mais c'est possible
[Musique]
et merci du coup pour le savent alors
attendu coup c'est kiki à saab série
castle géré perdu mon truc cécile x qui
as avec avec switch prime merci tonton
donc les bonnes affaires tour c'est un
pour gagner autre chose serait une
énorme non en tout reprend dé 8,0 à
pranger de ça va aussi mais ça peut-être
maxime pourrait pourrait rester dans la
partie
au nom de qui al'avantage c'est
nepomniachi qu'un avantage décisif mais
peut-être qu'ils ne le convertir à part
on ne sait pas ça dépend que de lui en
fait en gros parce que là on fait le
câline maxime en g2 est perdu donc ce
que maximis faire c'est quand il va
trembler contre jeu avec la dame qui
arrive peut-être des perpétuelles ou
quoi mais si les blancs font le coup
parfait il y en a un paquet mais en fait
en gros si un geste bien il ya juste
rien à faire torpiller une baisse de -
et voilà
mais bon et merci à mon goût de 22
femmes qui s'adonnent avec switch
travail merci tonton les tweets shoot
lyme qui pleuvent fab
et puis tu prime qui pleuvent
bon écoute soit marché de trucs qu'on va
donner alors bien qu'au bout il y a un
père betts est né pauvre kf 6 oui on l'a
vu il ya exactement tu peux rencontrer
parce que c'est une grotte au sundance
illustrative et là il y aura un père
pète en passant par angers 4 bon il ça
c'est le piège en fait c'est on va dire
que dans les cas trois coupes aussi via
tous rangs des huit tours c1 et
cavaliers f6 tour c'est un je pense ça
finit vraiment la partie s'empêche de
l'âme c6 on a vu avec fap qu' il y avait
plus grand chose à faire le problème
c'est que rld à 9,7 pour entrer sur la
colonnade sur un cavalier 6 donc c'est
ça ça clôt vraiment le débat donc il ya
tour c'est un qui clôt le débat il ya
cavaliere
il ya tout reprendre et 8 qu'il a cet
avantage
qui laisse encore un peu de chance à
maxime de rester en vie et ya cavani m6
qui fait nul donc en gros voilà les
trois choix de yann et il va falloir
choisir le bon quoi parfaire choisir
qualif six mois oui maman pattie va pas
le faire enfin je vois pas tellement
parce qu'il va voir alors à tandis que
tours prend des buts rennais 8e 6-6
pions prend d'amd un échec
on nous dit qu'après trois jeux 2 et
d'un match est un match 5 mai reprend g2
est d'alger ivey hayart watch de
peut-être direct non maintenant ok mais
c'est très bizarre en fait j'ai ce que
fait je vais juste un coup tu joues pas
oui bon il se trouve que c'est toujours
mieux pour les plans d'après leur dis
mais ça c'est pas vous qui regardez cela
suffit tour des vies tout cavalier apsys
est en lente tu peux trouver tour c'est
un c est enfin avouer que ça a du sens
envers les noirs la menace c'est ton
tour
je suis enfin un truc du plus basique
possible donc tu vas faire quelque chose
comme ça à ecublens et dans tellement de
variantes la dame 8 vient c6 nous faire
des clous agissent à mener qu'en fait tu
fais une pierre deux coups quoi c'est
juste la prophylaxie condamne ces six et
évitant prendre il ya pas de tour des
notables quelques gars sur g53 pranger
de dames g6 même charisme en son nom
mais je l'avais fait d'amérique et
articles parus aujourd'hui même dame b 4
était injuste rien n'est même pas une
menace
non non non mais c'est son côté dames f5
cavalli assiste maintenant à la rigueur
et la dame comme ça elle couvre tout
couac ouvre bel convenez 2,5 et merci
attend encore un tweet suprême qui tombe
ça fait plaisir voilà il ya un peu d un
peu des choses qui tombent positivement
et le switch prime il est venu de
millien 1701 qui a lâché son switch frei
merci tonton ça fait plaise on est à 61
61 à 61 abonnés sur sur la scène de
chasse comme la ccl cool ça fait plaise
ça fait plein je fais une petite pub
pour la série de vidéos sur le pion
isolé parce que quelqu'un peut mettre le
lien en fait parce qu'avec tout ce que
j'ai ouvert
c'est quelqu'un de trouver le lien et
mettre le petit lien pour la série de
vidéos sur le pion isolé ce serait cool
et encore un switch prime qui tombe
c'est sinestro 93 merci tonton pour pour
le twitch problème tu fais rêver blouse
bleue pour toi chaos qui lie la france
est en grès pour soutenir maxime dommage
que cela ne porte pas ses fruits
merci à tous ceux qui foulent au la
chaîne aussi et voilà elle ferait de la
chanter avec l'ami 96 qui lâche le
switch prime merci tonton à faim ajoute
voir votre dévotion du live on sait
jamais si on voit quoi this way et du
col fra champ que la merci pour le lien
je vais leur mettre je voulais
progresser sur le pion isolé je vais
vous mettre le lien des deux côtés joli
cadeau de noël vous avez les 30
premières minutes ils nous disent tour
c'est un jouet d'anciens jeux ben on en
mettra peut-être des coutelas je regarde
sur sur le sur le live vidéo je l'ait
pas encore mais il ya un léger décalage
de son conte adéquat branché mais si tu
l'as pas tout non plus pour le sens chez
moi j'ai une épaule on a 47 minutes et
l'isfec news info chat faut toujours
faire gaffe
il faut toujours faire gaffe av
les ans les infos follow les matins je
vous tue on fait un peu la pub réseaux
sociaux du coup à skis et beaucoup de
retweets sur mon truc tiens je vais
regarder ça tourne bien tous ont été
suivis ou pas mais en tout cas sur le
live je vois pas de joue pas bien
réfléchi on laisse réfléchir
bayer 19 retweet 58 j'aime rester
c'était pas c'est pas mal non non
c'était vraiment pas terrible peu
importe après on peut on en effet fable
a maintenant j'ai envie de te dire plus
rien ne nous touchent non non c'est pas
un truc qui nous touche particulièrement
c'est juste je comprendrais jamais quand
je pars confiant des lives ben talha on
essaie 1500 quoi ok voilà sur 1500
personnes comment commentait que 50
personnes qui font un truc ça prend
quand même cinq secondes
enfin cette demande de cliquer sur le
lien et n'atteint light quoi est sûre et
sur facebook 59 aussi qu'en fin mais je
veux dire c'est incroyable ben on
n'approuve pas se demander pourquoi les
échecs sont pas populaires c'est tout
cudos 555 merci pour pour le prime merci
tonton voilà ça c'est ça c'est des gens
bien qui lâche le prime non mes bêtes
pour le goût en plus c'est que vous ayez
des gens qui lâche le prime ok c'est
cool et même y met un peu la main à la
poche ou comme la c1 cliquant fait
passer ça te demande pas un centime sa
demande rien en investissement et c'est
ça qui me dépasse je comprends tout on
n'est pas les moyens de s'abonner de
faire un don de faire un tipi ok ça
c'est des trucs c'est autre chose c'est
très généreux de la part des gens qui le
font et qui veulent soutenir
c'est toujours très cool mais il n'y a
pas de problème pour les gens qui le
font pas parce que juste eu peut ne pas
pouvoir le faire mais ne pas re tweeté
quelque chose numéro du temps de
l'argent avant mais le live like et
surnom mais même le leak et mâcha passé
je sais pas qui s'engagent tellement
rien c'est quoi un tweet frings pour les
gens qui ont amazon prime ils peuvent
donner un switch prime gratuitement
ça rapporte à peu près 1 euros à la
chaîne un peu moins ou un peu plus
je sais jamais c'est un dollar 1 euro 1
$ 25 et est du coup pour toi c'est
gratuit et ça m'a zone qui paye en fait
site amazon prime salut samedi paye
amazon faye buralistes que amazon mais
la daronne à l'abri bon il faut qu'il
réfléchisse je passais blanchis chaque
fois qu'ils réfléchissent pour c'est un
jouet que d'anciens jouets c'est sûr tu
l'as plaisir j'ai dit ok mon brave on
n'est pas aux jambes bien bravo dans le
sens où il y avait beaucoup quoi
cambadélis ça me rappelle le sommes
quand même fait la loupe et la qualif
aux candidats il ya deux ans je t'écoute
et depuis un long trajet en voiture
ouais je sais pas encore raté rater un
c'est pas moi c'est pas bon signe pour
cela on puisse à auxerre qui joue bien
la dame a en plus la dernière fois
contre 1 rognon c'était quand même un
énorme combat ce final armageddon au
bout du bout du bout il n'y avait pas eu
de tremblant toi quand tu me dire à
l'étranger en armagnac non mais la
deuxième rapide
ouais c'était une promenade vers sur la
somme il a perdu en dix minutes
c'est terrifiant que je me sens vraiment
mal je sens j'ai transpiré de folie j'ai
une équipe où j'ai les yeux qui brûlent
faggion superballe là c'est horrible tu
d'oberthur
je suis ouais bah écoute surtout un bail
est juste sur notre jared à l'exemple de
leurs aînés pas et pas des chats patois
près de carhaix qui tu n'as plus de
talent là j'ai pas j'ai pas le temps
bruxelles a glissé la grippe s'annoncer
pas la grippe j'ai ouvert la fenêtre
la grippe c'est autre chose c'est la
grippe tc un ordi je m'énerve et puis
enfin je veux non mais je vais faire un
tour j'ai tapé dans un ballon enfin je
sais pas en fait je m'énerve jeu non là
je peux pas en réalité je me barre juste
en fait je me barre de leur dis je jette
un truc je m'égare dix minutes et
peut-être ça va mieux ou pas d'ailleurs
mais je reste pas assise dans le truc qu
est ce que ça me fait ruminer je
m'énerve encore plus leur domination ce
fameux bombe
en fait je comprends pas enfin je
remplissais pas la première fois par la
deuxième fois par la troisième fois sa
quatrième fois dans les cinq jurys quasi
thème pauvre madame 7 et puis on enfin
où on n'en parle plus j'ai envie de dire
brégeon la souffrance en fait non mais
deux ans il n'y a pas d'autre choix non
mais je sais bien qu'il faut vite quoi
enfin jouer le plus possible que le
souhaitent dames 7
matt fini c'est pour les blancs sont
gagnants par exemple chez dams est
admettons que j'attaque a rédigé deux
ans prison menaces matt mondial 6 vers
yvan plus il ya tout quoi madame points
6 admettons sa gamme variée on se
retrouve qu'avec une pièce de plus et
oui c'est finalement tu as montré une
variante simple mais elles donnent tous
à peu près ça non mais à bosse à
tivaouane n'y a pas de choix enfin il il
a passé une demi-heure sans retour c'est
un jeune il a tout regardé donc madame
s'attend plus à louise harel n'a pas vu
d'armé cette base s'il agit donc ce que
je de pain c'est fini c'est fini tu
joues un coût du crédit menace que cinq
quoi et puis si les blancs font les cons
ça va ya aucune raison qu'il le fasse et
merci hariri qu eric hall aux bobos qui
après un tweet frei merci tonton merci
de relâcher le prime nous peut pas
parler plus supprimer la pub pas trop
d'excitation aujourd'hui quoi mais c'est
bien on a des belles plumes du veau à
serrières parole en parlant de cuba les
boums quoi alors pas bonnes a dit adams
est ou pas on revient dans une minute
non ça fait du bien ouvrir la fenêtre
c'est une bonne idée merci alter désolé
mais amazon prime est payant non ah bah
oui amazon tran huy ah oui ces sites
amazon prime que switch prime et gratuit
après tu peux tu abonnés à la chaîne
sans ça c'est autre chose
d'emblée jean loup jean bas prix amazon
prime pour suivre la chaîne trouve
qu'ils ont amazon prime est donc comme
ils ont droit à un abonnement gratuit
voilà du coup un homme prend aussi fort
caillé si ses formes un peu moins moi
j'ai cet écart à 9,6 à m moi je suis
peut-être puisse offrir c'est que je
fais dames deux métiers d'altran 17,3
méningite
c'est bon ça s'arrête là j'ai fait un
petit baroud d'honneur sur g5 tu prends
ya jamais tour j'ai vite
ouais ça va ressembler un truc comme ça
à la fin de la partie il a fait
qu'alexis faute fab
ouais bah sky prend 1,3 manon ouais bon
on reprend un petit espoir allez on
était dedans encore femmes
non mais vraiment oui oui c'est que d'un
processus de vente
ouais c'était gagner gagner mais qui
existe en fait c'est ce que j'aurais
joué oui mais comme toi parce que tu
fais qui est histoire et chaque équipe
dames pro 6 3 bouts jusqu'à liège 6,6
après l'échec
bon après tout le temps de réfléchir
mais bon il a calculé ce truc 1% mais
bon c'est quand même temps - 3 - 2 50
mais bon on n'est pas encore mariée à
quelqu'un il ya des petites arnaques là
je sens oui et des pizzas gratuites et
-3 20 prend 1 6 3 et fuite et là je sais
pas non mais tu peux tenter dé paix rhdp
kelly qui peuvent nous essayer au tour
du roi tenue d'un premier de deux dames
2 acquis matériels mentez pas long ouais
moi j c'est pas fini bah du coup c'est
fini fab
ce serait extraordinaire ainsi on a
envie fab
oui on en vient on dirait quand il a des
trucs penser que oui là d'un projet ce
qui arrive si c'était vraiment fini
allez on peut on peut peut-être saurait
mais à pareloup une question d'hommes
prend un f6 rouge suite qu'il y ait six
tours
tour 17 c'était quoi la la tête reprend
mais bon c'est dur à trouver
non mais en fait c'est sa fable les
turcs ça gagne et à l'autre à guetter de
pluzz.fr du coup je comprends très bien
enfin c'est pas tellement une faute quoi
ça oui c'est juste ça a été tellement
désespérée pour vraiment réaliser on
n'est même plus envie qu'eux non pas du
goût ce qui soit assez logique allez
allez allez maxime j'y allais pour le
chat
à une époque rac quoi à mes agents peu
plus fait j'en fais tellement plus elle
ou le tour à tour eiffe cette dame des
huîtres faute en fait n'ont même pas
d'orgueil juste le avec l'ordinateur
apple ça peut être un coup si mauvais il
va faire il va trouver un échec repartir
ailleurs sur 10 à leur toit est en fait
il va te faire dans le français 7e place
et mat
ok va faire rage sac ce que tu aurais
pas cet état de fait nous mêmes dams et
6,1 d'hommes étranges et 21.3 attaque
c'est un tacle le roi est très bon allez
vas-y joue vite n'ai pas fait de la
merde pourquoi mais je vais vite c'est
trop d'honneur
ok mais h56 trouve le coût d'accès 2
c'est vrai que c'est une double attaque
qui fait mal nommée c'est pas dur si tu
rien arranger deux en fait
bah elle va être en jeu s'ils sont plus
aux normes non mais on va faire quoi que
ce soit bien mes tarifs 7 et 8 bat toi
de me prendre 6 kheddam 2
donc ils seront quatre princes est là
mais ok là encore par un coup quoi mais
toi tu cèdes faut le faire non mais oh
qu'est ce que dit le redis c'est très
fort torres a qui vous fait d'hommes des
huit échecs roi montebourg csat et
change le tour mais non mais ça va enfin
je veux dire vous fait peur en blitz
email en fait je regarde pas cette
époque à la barre à ce qu'en plus tu
t'attaques et adams a pas d'échec et
tout mais je vous assure et juste qui
joue vie qui veut entrer dans le court
il ya trop bien on va voir des signes
patois que ça normal
qu'il peut merdouille et 1 et pauillac a
mis la pression en et la retourne à la
nuit alfredo lâchant que là ok c c'est
franchement possible de se tromper
oui vraiment genre je veux dire dame c8
qui semble juste un coup normal leur dit
de ne plus qu un saint quentin ok c'est
gagnant pas tant que ça tout d'un coup
c'est un grossier c'est tout ça à [ __ ]
toi là tu te rends pas compte que tu es
plus gagné en fait non quand tu dis ok
je ne l'étais de puces tout va bien et
alors dit tu dis tu en prends h5 que
c'est un cépage à tout faire et il te
disais un coût d'un des trois ça je peux
le comprendre
je peux vous le truc c'est que sur dame
prend il veut faire dame c3 échangés
mais
mais bon il faut espérer dames série
tempête mais deux et là tout d'un coup
en fait ça peut devenir très chaud c'est
très chouette km2 c'est très chaud non
mais bon problème de dames 2e tour cet
oedème des huit mois j'ai sept tours 7
en fait le problème c'est que
contrairement à 6 8 6 mm 6 avril à il ya
un coup très fort de notre deuxième coup
d'ordi dame g5 oui ok ça c'est très
jouable pas juste eu protège ça tu
protèges -site je vous fais ça ouais ça
c'est même plus ou moins ok mais encore
dame de ham et la médaille à damas six
et dix-huit 1.361 pop songs
oui mais tu empêches d'un projet de mais
bon le truc c'est que dan des huit
justin quoi mais même torse sat bains je
veux dire de voir tu vends et si tu veux
voir mes amis et surtout reif 8
donc c'est d'apporter ou non c'est moi
qui bouge
ah oui c'est vraiment la partie dams est
ok et maintenant sur tours fc a et
surtout été à tort ses huit noms à 9,5
bon là des toutous yens honda faisait
six mois que je vais manger 500 c'est le
coût que j'aurais joué et lors des 3es
pas si clair ok c'est la ville max eux
déclarent moins inquiets précédé des
logiques tourage trois cavalières 4,2 à
taux plein de petits coups de fouets
gigote tu as c'est pour ça que maxime il
est tellement dur à battre parce que
c'est incroyable
bon point de tours c'est cette eau si
c'est ça c'est le couple garde parce que
pour être franc on ajoute on prend on
reprend dans les feuillages de paix des
chocs et ça c'est très facile à calculer
pour les joueurs de ce niveau là et il
ya aussi d'un projet si ce qui donne
envie d'air oui oui mais dans ce sens là
mais déjà regarde le truc c'est possible
non mais regarde à tout d'un grand et si
c'est encore plus en france parce que tu
fais quoi est fait tout rêve 7
euh juste à me ranger 600g cette source
et si tu fais ensuite maintenant dame
changé ici c'est j'ai aussi ça comme fin
trop coûts et pas 2 catane est en plus à
deux pions plus dans mail hayatou qui en
fait ouais non les bons gars figures
sont trop mais bon sur ses sept sacs
albatros latence et cette fête c'est pas
tous gagnent mais juste pour c'est vrai
mais je suis d'accord j'aurais joué tour
c'est satan parti c'est sûr qu'elle est
très linéaire l'hallali tour f1 prise
tour comprise d'un mais fin ça et là tu
le vois n'y a pas d'échec c'est
tellement thématiques déjà ordonné fin
de vue trois de ceux là même qui l'a
fait d'armes francis roy ici ouest /
gagnant mais c'est bizarre nos peurs
fait tout ok mais la variante elle est
facile aussi
mais toutes les montres 5 mais passons
alors dit aussi mes tours soit 3,6 du
coup seul coup j'étais en france 5,5
échec échec échec mais je suis d'accord
avec toi que l'autre était plus simple
parce que ça là tu as encore des échecs
comme nantes après le 35e mais complique
un peu la vie mais bon le problème c'est
que n'importe quel coût
avec en plus maintenant tout est
transposition en finale c'est lorsqu'il
arrive à gratter trois purs fait un deux
ou trois pions en l'espace de trois
coups ce pénible
bon ben follow la chaîne dont j'ai envie
de dire follow follow la chaîne à fond
les catalans qui je sais cette partie
bas à 0,1 pour cent de chances des
fennecs oury bah c'est pas parti pour
une bouffée des grèves ces dénis des
grimaces à la ahl al hanak aqua gym gym
hausse de bonheur écoeurant lors été
nombreux à regarder cette partie long
mais demain on peut égaliser info
revenir et pousse à fond et puis après
il y aura encore voilà finale du coup ce
soir un meneur d'hommes ouija même en
cas de défaite c'est pas fini il faut
encore que les peaux convertissent
exactement
agrandissez cru mais moi je la gagne
cette position avait peut-être devant
une énorme pression tu la rate
écoute
je vous le regrette un peu la victoire
de sophie cercle de la victoire de dépôt
contre sawyer ben on était tellement
confiant avec toi femme kouassi soviets
est finie bah oui oui mais du coup on
était en mode on veut un match décisif
maxime est plus fort il va montrer que
c'est le patron n'a fait rattraper en
dix grands délires comme ça de dire non
mais ok non plus n'est possible dans ce
seul jeu et damas je crois jouer nos
matches joués femmes non ils jouent
beaucoup de calculs et je vois sur le
fil idées aux longs cheveux très belle
façon une voix qui l'appareil peut plus
raté en fait face à huit bombes ont voté
pour je n'ai pas bien vu fort connais
pas je suis pas d'accord le tour des uns
c'était quand même une énorme erreur
par ailleurs il te réussit là l'après
pas de quoi après la prépa et fait une
grosse faute qui a pris là bien fini un
même parti mais globalement bonne partie
bon choix d'ouverture bonne prépa
beaucoup de choses mais n'en a pas une
partie parfaite mais ce n'est pas une
partie exemplaire je trouve que gris
tout cas fait plus pour gagner que n'est
pas ici bon on va écouter demain demain
fou déjà petite petite pub fab
ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
une petite pub déjà commencé fred sarre
je vais montrer bon notamment
bon vers un dépôt qui peut craquer
demain femmes il peut maxime que fin de
partie c'est plein de choses oui
au pire des cas n'est pas encore gagné
il ya croisade sillage catane quoi toi
tu veux montrer la bonne mine pour les
moins courageux cette machine voilà on
perd une tour avec les noirs l'euro est
faible on sert mater et voilà non non il
a perdu c'est fini il y aura encore
demain le major la garde et on a perdu
une bataille n'a pas perdu la guerre
c'est quand même pas terrible et ont pu
faire des coeurs n'est encore les sports
navarin on en est réduit à peut-être
espérer d'abord après ce très beau que
sur un navire a quitté halifax et aussi
pour le jeu mais un jeu mais un raid à
quelqu'un ou pas oui c'est à qui si elle
qui a maille à sitges non c'est la
chaîne chaise comme j'en vois suite
chasse comme mais elle exclut ceux qui
on s'en fout oui bah j'en vois jazz
comme jean-paul internationale
allez hop on our watch score
internationale et a du coup on se
retrouve on se retrouve demain 14h pour
la suite
un chacun